[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right mike check mic check lords
what's going on anchor man what's going
on brother
hope you're feeling better brother
thinking about you yes please everybody
stay safe wear a mask man be careful out
there
you know alex what's going on keep your
tcl safe
christopher hart what's going on how my
levels are sounding yo make sure i'm
sounding all right
talking to y'all what's going on mostly
martinez from twitch what's going on bro
what's going on i see you let me know
how my levels are
so y'all can hear me all right i see you
in there man
salute to you let's charge you for the
yo stitch it's not it's not great bro
you got to stay
you got to stay thank you chris i
appreciate it
that sounds good turn your mic up a tiny
peak just a tiny peak
see i will do that but then they say my
life my laugh is too loud
but you know how i like to laugh so
so let's see how it go i might tell
myself slightly slight
question how many people in the chats
heard of mr beast i'm curious how many
people in the chat
has heard of mr beast
i never seen that name what's going on
corey mosley what's going on so yeah we
should have the king rolling up
here soon spoke to brandon he'll be
pulling up as well
you know what i'm saying actually
angerman says he's heard of him you know
i'm saying yeah
akw one week to the series x you know
them giveaways going down today
you know them giveaways happening make
sure y'all can't solve
scrub nerves what's going on what's
going on
yeah lucia said who hasn't heard of this
to be so they know about
he said i know my beast ain't give out
tc yo i'm done
yeah you ain't nice to me when we do
switch topics so stop it
don't try to play nice now don't be on
good behavior now cause we're giving
away consoles
don't try to be nice
yo anyway about the mute because you
know king pull it up
and uh we will get brandon tyrell in
here
and have some fun today big show big
show a lot of stuff going on
so we will see y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
and we are live
[Laughter]
welcome to the iron laws podcast and now
live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 182 you hit that refresh
button don't log that y'all
can watch it there too and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got halo infinite losing
a top director
playstation plus gearing up for game
pass
what what'd you say kid you're hilarious
no echo oh yeah echo yeah
what about i'm i'm good i'm good i don't
know if you guys hear anything yeah i'm
i'm good i don't i don't yeah i don't
hear it maybe
i think yeah that's definitely on your
side and the nintendo direct
partner showcase to discuss so we gonna
get right into it i want to introduce a
lord who is not only a seasoned veteran
within our games industry
but whose pure passion truly shines in
all aspects of journalism
and multimedia whether it be his balance
perspectives on game development
or informative renewal analysis all done
with the utmost professionalism
introducing the senior editor at ign
and a panelist of podcast unlocked
the coffee lord of breakfast
dominator of unlocked trivia and my
fellow red and gold 49er brethren
whoa let's go baby live from oakland
and kind enough to make his debut into
the realm
of the lords my man lord
brandon tyrell how we doing sir
good morning good morning yeah
that was a hell of an intro i gotta say
appreciate it
i appreciate that appreciate it you are
a lord
at what you do it's only right we show
you the proper respect here
at the round table first of all how you
doing what's been going on
with you and ign and just what you've
been what you've been playing man
oh things are good uh it's the busy
season you know so
we are full steam ahead on a bunch of
you know next gen is a huge topic coming
up
obviously big games coming out for next
gen so
just lots of work like lots and lots of
work but uh but it's good
playing wise um i'm kind of bouncing all
over i'm still messing around with hades
very happy very happy with that choice
and
you know it's on my short list i gotta
say it's on my shortlist for game of the
year so
that's what we're doing is that is that
much yeah i agree
it's so good it's so good uh a couple of
others to come out
i still want to check out but yeah i'm
definitely going to be looking at that
one come
voting time no doubt man no doubt man so
much going on man
again pleasure to have you we got to get
this show rolling
so you already know we have the full
hospital gaming those original lords of
the realm here at the round table
with our updated time sensitive guest
intros
[Laughter]
but goes to the co-host my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of his own world and the how of the
young wolf
my man lord addict how are we doing sir
did you just put some random names
in his own world man i feel like i feel
like you're an addict
it needs to be like a vote before you
just start adding to our names
how are you gonna complain first yeah i
say i don't update y'all yeah intros
did i update it and we don't play the
intros you update the but we don't get
them
you know say no what you've been playing
sir
uh i've been playing watchdog legions um
actually i you know first off i want to
apologize for missing two weeks
uh definitely a lot of stuff going on uh
one thing i do want to point out to the
chat is there's this game called uh
vigil the longest night you guys should
really go check that out yes
yeah you know it's a it's a really good
like kind of dark so it's like
metroidvania type of game and i think
you guys would enjoy that uh for whoever
that's relevant to i know a lot of
people in the chat don't like those kind
of souls games um
you know watch dogs is uh we'll get to
that here we'll
let's hit you with time already
he just came back
that has been it said you know i just
want to remind meds that i have
access to uh to block you
i want you to be very close to that
shout out to me oh wow oh we got
somebody joining around so soft
i'll give me a moment oh that's my dude
that's right
hold on a second i apologize we have
rain g4 welcome to the realm sir
what the question is up in there for our
brother man thank you for joining the
realm so i appreciate it
shout out to general max it's brandon
oakland in the house that's what's up
okay reppin and
of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity
and patreon of the iron bank mommy
lord sovereign how we doing sir doing
well man doing very well
tired but you know it's always but you
know
work it out yeah working hard managed to
get in a little bit of
of ufc and boxing last night i know king
elaborated a little bit on that and uh
and then in terms of what i've been
playing i actually got to play something
this past week a little bit so i got
like like lord brandon i'm playing hades
uh yeah
definitely on my short list like i said
last week i think right
as of right now it is my game whoa
it's really it's up there wow
so i got to play that a little bit more
and i still suck at it but whatever i
just i love you
and then i got to i played the demo for
age of calamity
um and i will just say that i don't like
musso games
no it's it is beautiful
i i'll watch a youtube video and i'll
get the lore i'll get the story
but in terms of the gameplay of a musso
game and it's i mean
everything that happens in the game is
bombastic every explosion every attack
is absolutely crazy it just feels like
it's on autopilot for me and it's
something that i don't i just don't
gravitate to so i played it
it was fine um everything about it in
terms of production value seems amazing
but it's just not for me yeah in terms
of first we get it
it's so good brother and of course we
have the incredible hulk of this aka
the access gamer oh the prophet of
xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
ooh beloved lord king how are we doing
sir
oh you know how i'm doing you so what it
was
happy halloweeny to all the people
i hope you got all your candies and hope
you checked them make sure the kids
you know didn't get anything bad from
these creeps out there
thank you thank you for the public
service announcement yes
yesterday i was watching uh javonte tank
davis
versus lito santa cruz at the first uh
boxing event that had uh live spectators
uh in attendance and um
it was something to behold mm-hmm i
thought leto
would be able to hold tank off if he can
take him deep
pause into uh later rounds
tank gave him an uppercut that separated
his consciousness from his body
was bent up under his body he folded up
like a lawn chair
he hit him with you know because if one
second he was there then the next second
he was not
and it got kind of scary because he
laid there literally oh probably
lifeless we don't know if he gonna make
it
oh i said the way he fell
i hope he can move all his limbs damn
because
he was a tank because tank was you know
celebrating across the ring and he
realized that lito was laying there a
little bit too long
yeah and then he got worried yeah yeah
that's what
he was possibly went over there but um
i'ma tell you right now
if any of you uh lightweight dudes think
you're gonna get in there with tank
you better watch yourself
so um would you be playing sir um
okay what's up i'm sorry i i i don't
know if you guys have noticed but we had
a poll up
okay it just uh for for the new emotes i
did take me a couple minutes to get it
took
care of but now in if you're a member of
the realm you have access
i was playing scourge uh scourge bringer
um on game pass
try that game it's fabulous um but you
know i'm right now on katana zero
um i i i ended the game and i started it
over again
right i love the game so much it's not a
roguelike it's just a
a pure action game with a rewind feature
it's one one hit kill it's a very uh
tough game to play but it's fantastic
and it is very rewarding if you if you
get past the board
definitely feel like you accomplished
something once you pass that board
and um i was watching the last word with
uh
with rick cackas shout
if you watch the new kos that's up um
you heard me give a complete shout out
to my man cod
on his way his journey back home to xbox
ppc from the evil pc yes uh we will be
ripping him from the so-called pc
unmastered race and he'll be back in
destiny
on xbox hey that cat daddy you see it's
it's meant to be
really chat really sir that's it sir all
right
attic if you're back if you want to get
those bars off as far i think we talked
about the new emotes
we had a poll up some stuff going on he
may have stepped away for a minute but
we'll get him on on his comeback
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi
unlocked lord cognito spell
mario escaped again yo they clowned it
over here spread that realness into the
realm of the iov and i'll tell you what
you want to hear but what you need
to hear yeah shout out to the last word
hebantis my man rick cackus who's in the
building some fun talk
like i said get ready for beyond light
check that out when you get a chance
hilarious show
as for me um it's been a control
soft or the oh really switch
the cloud powered the vastly in addition
there's ray tracing here there's ray
tracing here
performance mode there's a graphics
board i was very very impressed
so uh yeah shout out to them and
obviously big that's let's get these
super chats real quick so
we got a couple okay so we have first of
all we have
douchey with the five dollars that sup
lord
great night of fights last night lord a
lord cog better beat control on switches
with that gate i see you baby feed the
wolves
then we have squirrely dan with the two
super chat addict's beard is mad grizzly
adams
yeah spirit as well and then we have
cedric h with the ten dollar super chat
good morning lords good morning to you
sir good morning good morning and then
we have give me a moment we have smitty
smith
with the five dollar super chat ghost
rider
hashtag stay collected yeah that goes
right that ghost ride is fire kicking
the statue so you already know
yeah then we have tony bryant with the
five dollar super chat
feed the wolves katana zero is the devil
the devil i say
shout out to tony blair where are the
gator in the picture i see you
yeah yeah and we can we have smitty
smith once again with the five dollar
super chat the last word is the best
word salute lord
thank you brother much much appreciate
it you already know so yeah we all
caught up man like i said so we got that
going on
but um yeah man we're going to breeze
through you know it's that time of the
month
again and um you know we're here at
lordsgaming.net man editorial team
we like to pay homage you know what i'm
saying to the great writers and the
scribes
in the realm you know we're super proud
of what we're doing as a website
and um just the consistent growth the
trajectory has been really cool to see
and all the contributions of the writing
team so um
yeah man it's that time of the month man
we definitely want to acknowledge
last month's most exceptional writer at
log
net that scribe of the month so for
october 2020 the scribe of the month
is hector ramirez aka
lord macho put your head down
what is going on don't scare describe
[Laughter]
but um to him man little matcha is
amazing he's all a pleasure to work with
he has been killing it with the articles
to walk throughs
get if y'all if you want to know about
get [ __ ] impact man he's got some
tremendous articles right now up on
kinship
impact obviously pre-pandemic king you
already know we worked with them all as
far as impacts
outstanding video production you know
his translation remember it assisting us
when we got the uh platinum games
interview with uh
rising star he's a definitely a rising
star
recently promoted you know saying to
assistant editors so
salute lord macho put your hands
together man
tremendously exactly i love what you're
doing
i've already taken care of the man we're
taking okay we've taken care of the
rewards he's in the chat
oh watch us in the chat watch us in the
chat he's laughing he's laughing he's
like
but you are describing the monster well
deserved man well deserved
and you already know you're gonna be
immortalized on the website if you go to
logicgaming.net
right now macho's name is his likeness
is there and you can see all his work
all the stuff that he's worked on again
outstanding work brother
logged in all day you're already no
salute my child
all right so we all caught up is addict
back nope not back okay
so um what i was gonna ask is uh now
that we got into oh actually get the
superchat for a second we have uh
tony bryant with the five dollar super
chat prayers up wise old gamer big
surgery tomorrow
putting it in the university will be
okay sir yes yeah
please man it's
send out prayers to our boy cat daddy
fat stack yeah he went through a
a situation over there with the
hurricane has some damage
thank you the family is okay but you
know uh you know
also also lord mojo blues is in the
hospital y'all
so um yeah definitely um send out to our
thoughts with him and his recovery and
stuff like that man but we gotta
move on have some fun hopefully in the
realm but um
yeah man what's up oh yeah that's right
no actually i'll let you describe it
because you know i don't know anything
about this game
we have one giveaway we're gonna set off
right now you already know november 10th
the beyond light
that stranger you don't want to say it
comes back into the realm
so um oh mojo's in the chat salute
brother thank you destiny's show in the
chat what's going on brother salute you
already know
um yeah so we wanna you know we had to
give away that tremendous
beyond light statue xbox edition it is
time to announce the winner soft
and the winner well before that once
again thank you to lord snow though
king of the band hammer um once again
lord snowdon had to sift through
literally almost a thousand uh bogus
entries
salutes all the frauds
you tried for all that's harder yeah you
tried but lord snow though
is not having that so the winner of our
destiny giveaway
is lord hollow fight
oh oh wow
the door what's going on brother exactly
exactly so
uh yeah i'm not gonna put you i'm not
gonna put the government out there
melvin we won't be
located so congratulations to you sir we
will get you all the information that's
necessary for you to receive
your game and your statute because that
uh i have to say
as someone who doesn't play destiny that
is a fantastic looking skill oh i think
y'all dice a beauty how could you even
know that you don't play that
i do have eyes that could be the worst
expansion that we ever have and we're
playing taking pity on
oh wow can't get i don't play that's
anything
you want to jump off the uh a boat with
us oh wait real quick before
addict says the emote thing sorry um so
ladies and gentlemen you know that today
is the day
today is the day we'll be giving away
this xbox series x and this playstation
five but it will
find out who wins yes you're gonna have
to wait to the end of the show exactly
you're gonna have to stay
around baby that's right you got to deal
with kicking that man
exactly this is halloweeny time
uh sir it's the first halloween's over
right all right listen um
halloweeny baby addict sir you want to
do the uh
yeah before before i was rudely
interrupted
staying iron lord stuff it wasn't like i
was just popping off but you know
we won't go into that you can do that
now you can do whatever you want
you know the lords we got we got a free
emote you know we we
like to give back let let the members in
the patreon choose what it was and
by like an overwhelming wasn't even
close time won
by i i'm wanting to say like 80
like ty won't buy a long shot so we have
that in the chat for you guys for the
moment
right now perfect show guns using it
yeah we got it
in the chat for the members you could
just throw that out if you guys
want it looks good you have to chat to
you dizzy's using it
the reason it took me so long is that i
had it i had to edit it no that looks
really good sir i like the chat
the time they're telling us to shut up
and move on with the time thank you all
right
they utilize it already so we have we
have a super chat from perfect show gun
for the five dollars welcome to the
realm lord brandon the iron lords
podcast is the only show
with a like button that supports all our
day our dna
[Music]
we're fully featured on our dna i uh
i approve that that's kind of messy i
love that that's kind of fun
so we all set guys we are all set let's
go all right let's get into it man so of
course you already know that we've
gotten into everything with the law has
been playing
all the sweepstakes we still got more
going on but now we want to focus on
lord
brandon tyrell his video game system
history
his journey into various roles in the
games industry including stops at namco
and ea
and of course what led him to becoming
the senior editor of ign
and the panelists of the amazing
unlocked so
brandon let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had
and what got you into gaming wow okay
well that's what a topic huh
uh yeah like i think most kids my age
uh i started with the nes that big gray
box we still have it downstairs it's
very yellow
now you know it's seen better days but
it does like it's it's a little piece of
my gaming history so i
you know i'm gonna hold on to it as long
as i can but absolutely
yeah i came up through nintendo i mean
the 80s and 90s were
were really dominated in the early parts
before you know i
i dipped out of nintendo i never got
into the snes unfortunately
i didn't grow i didn't grow up real well
off so like
a new console was was you know every
couple years for christmas maybe if it
was good
right um so i went i went to the nes
to the uh then i jumped ship and went to
genesis oh you traded you came to the
good guys
continue genesis does
there's nothing i hate more than old
sports talk yeah
that we're a guaranteed touchdown
shout out to the money plays of joe
montan bro
amazing now because there was two right
it was a standard one
and then there was a sequel which was
sports talk about i get it right
the first one i i don't believe the
first one was sports talk the second one
was and then everyone after that was
yeah so
which one you had uh love brandon i
don't remember i'll be honest with you
that was a long time ago
yeah no no no it worked no it was
quarterback club i think
wow okay but again like my memory not
great i don't remember what i had for
lunch yesterday so
yeah it's weird like my my early gaming
memories there are like very vivid
uh pictures of games that i was playing
marble madness zelda
super mario brothers and then i
basically jumped like 15 years
uh but no i went nes than genesis uh
and then i got that uh nice that
gorgeous hunk of
translucent green plastic that was the
n64
[Music]
with the expansion card that actually
probably has the memories for him
that was that was the big item i
remember i freaked out when i got that
so did a lot of gaming on the n64 and
then i kind of uh
i think i went playstation after that i
didn't get a ps1 when it was out
i didn't get a ps2 either but i had
friends i'd go over to their houses i'd
play that
and then years later my my mom picked me
up um
the ps was it the psa it's basically the
one that you fit in your pocket
oh yeah yeah this was this was like the
the mid-aughts or the early odds so
everyone wore
parachute pants or cargo pants and like
i would carry that bad boy around like
to school
yes um even though i didn't have the
display or the wires or anything
you just had to come out as good like a
security blanket yeah
um but yeah like i started getting
really into rpgs at that time so played
a lot of like
uh breath of fire uh legend of dragoon
the chrono series
oh that was such good games yeah all
attic approves
attic approves yeah i mean you know
games are so expensive back then but you
get 90 hours out of a good jrpg
so now you can spend 90 hours on fetch
quests
oh god we'll talk about my wow history
in a minute
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so uh pl playstation x
um and then i
i don't i don't recall getting another
console until i purchased my
first one i i bought my xbox the
original xlg
yeah so what what prompted you to
transition what
because again they relatively new at
that time right yeah playstation's
pretty much your market leader and then
microsoft kind of jumps in into the game
so
what excited you about wanting to get
the the og xbox
same thing that excites me about xbox
now is the community like i had friends
i had friends who owned one
and i heard i heard tales of this new
shooter
i heard tales of this new shooter that
you could play locally with your friends
on a map called blood gulch legendary
and i was like what is this new shooter
i don't know it doesn't sound like it's
for me and i had seen the halo
commercials and i'll be honest with you
i was like that looks stupid
i'm like one of the very few people that
i got into the xbox brand because of
fable i didn't get into because i had so
trusted yeah so fable was my next my
next big uh
big purchase but i i got into my my best
friend in the world
you know that i knew since i was i was
12. i was over at his house every
weekend and he had a bunch of little
brothers so we always had four people to
play halo 1.
um and so it was just blood gulch battle
creek
like like all of these amazing maps
oh my god and this uh was it locked down
i want to say or was that halo 2
that was a little too okay but this this
like this relationship went on forever
we
we would play local halo uh through one
two
three um yeah so there's just a lot of
really really good memories for me
and then you know i'm a big like art i'm
a big fantasy nerd i'm a big
role-playing game nerd uh
so like fable came out and i was like i
remember the trailer and i've talked
about this on unlocked before
like it's just sweeping camera coming
down it's like welcome to the world of
i'll be on and i'm like i mean
that's all you do i mean there's a
werewolf i mean
you know it's you know it's crazy like
the this this origin that this
remake that that gives me the same vibe
that the trailer that we just had for
the for this new favorite
like with the uh the toad eating up the
ferry and stuff
that has the same body i cannot wait to
see gameplay because
what really sold me about fable was um
hey i mean the setting
it's fantasy game but it was western
right like i i was able to connect to it
in ways that i couldn't really
with jrpgs i find jrpgs to be very
character-centric and that's sort of
that's sort of one of the hallmarks of
them right whereas western rpgs tend to
lean a little more towards immersion
like you see with skyrim
yes so so with fable like
i remember and thinking back like how
dumb i was
um i'm thinking back and i'm like wait
when you get cut in the face you get a
scar
next generation oh yeah
you go good you get a halo and like
small little gimmicks i remember
thinking
this is the future guys
i remember peter molina like i remember
him talking about it i'm like oh my god
i remember the first time i played fable
and i and i went to the chapel
storm i think that's what his name was
and they said i gotta sacrifice people
to get like a legendary dark weapon i'm
like what is good what are they doing
right now
you had to get followers take them to
that place and sacrifice them to be able
to get like the dark weapon that was in
it jesus
yeah it was dark it was dark that game
was a lot a lot more adult than people
remember
that's like and shout out i know he gets
a lot of crap sometimes
oh i'll never forgive him for uh milo
and project natal but he knows
how to sell peter model know he knew how
to sell that thing man like he was the
face of these games
as far as the presentation i remember
those trailers little brand like you
were saying it was revolutionary for its
time it did a lot of things
you know what i'm saying i could i could
believe so faye would definitely let us
walk
for you on the other og yeah yeah yeah
and then peter
knew i mean you're right he was
excellent at selling his vision
um i think he's an excellent salesman
and a really
like really uh innovative sort of kind
of design
mind yeah um but there were some
elements where it's like you're gonna
care about the dog
spoiler alert no yeah i didn't really
care about the dog
i was sad when the thing happens we
worried about spoilers
is that approved the game the game's
like i feel like 20 years old if you
ain't played it by now
that's your fault man i don't know what
they're gonna pull back for the remake
so i'm going to go
light but there are mo there are things
that better not be no dog like that in
this room
it just felt it just felt like it was
set up with a
reaction out of you you know it's like
hey do you want this yes
yep yo shout out to hyde in the chat
debauchery achievement
oh my god yes though real quick uh
little brother
let's get a couple of super chats real
quick uh yes we have
uh stitch with the two dollar super chat
you should start with the last topic i
guess he wants all that
nintendo smoke first yeah um then we
have big cloud gaming with the five
dollar super chat it's the lord's day
hit that like button
uh lol david over here looking like the
bone collector with that mask on
we got a different one
now i'm vengeance
and then we have six lair with the two
dollar super chat good morning sir say
something
please the lord of tv optimization
and opens
yeah we're caught up all right no doubt
yeah tremendous uh okay so then you tran
did you
so those are most of the standouts you
played on og and then you transitioned
to 360 or
what was your next progression uh there
were a ton man like you know that mecca
got me into xbox live of course halo
yeah and ever since then i've been
in the xbox ecosystem i haven't left of
course i've picked up other systems but
um you know i bought a ps3 uh with the
uncharted and
uh god of war packages i don't think i
ever opened those packages but
really i'm not throwing [ __ ] or anything
i'm just like
you know i i get really excited about
video games and i'm like i must have it
and when you know you hit a certain age
you start having a little bit of
disposable income you can make some real
bad decisions
yes um but yeah yeah you know ever since
ever since picking up the og xbox i went
out and you know by that time i had a
job so i bought my 360 then i
put three and then one and so sort of
the rest is history but
what really got me was the 360. that was
my that was my sort of coming-of-age
console
where i felt like i turned myself into
the gamer i am today
talk that talk yeah man like xbla was
sort of my stomping grounds monday night
combat like
they were what i loved about xbla is
that
i didn't have to spend 60 dollars on
that
yeah but also i was just a huge fan of
like gotham city imposters right
super goofy on the premise batman versus
joker squad and they fight
in like a counter-strike style with a
bunch of goofy abilities
but that's what i loved about xpla is
you jump in there you find a game
right and you just play it until you get
really good at it and you're pumped
stomping
and it only cost you 15 bucks and you
had it
nice such a great time absolutely i had
a big problem there for a while with the
impossible games
the impossible one yeah yeah yeah he
made laura brown made a good point
because
you know what i loved about it too with
the with the blades and the way the
interface was on the 360
i felt it was more accommodating to
those smaller indie titles and
stuff got a little bit more visibility
and like you said you find out i mean
remember what state of decay i remember
all these
like games that you know you're just
like what's this and you just plucked
out a little bit and it was just like
wow they're so
amazing you know i mean so i definitely
definitely could relate to you on that
there's definitely a discoverability
issue right yeah there are more games
released this year than they were last
year than they were the year before and
it's going to keep going
so it's tough it's tough and you also
had great promotional things like summer
of arcades right
yeah that was the fun part i love this
american gig with the masks
you enjoyed that game boy some of our
arcades
we used to wait for the summertime to
pop up and we know what games was going
to pop into the arcade hell yeah it was
like they were vehicles too
they were big what was it it was two a
month yeah
yep shadow complex castle crashers like
shadow complex was so fantastic into the
background and into the fork
oh man awesome right now
anyway
the thing for me was also um the
evolution i'm just curious how you're
surprised at this point yeah why am i
even surprised with the kick
oh let's do it well but also was to be
like the evolution
of xbox live brandon right we had like
you just
you know party chat and it just it just
kept expired we
og xbox i always felt like i said was a
pioneer in that regard for just getting
xbox live to the mask getting out the
ground that was that was cool you know
what i'm saying
but i always remember like you know what
i'm saying those big games and i believe
like during the call of duty era and all
this stuff
and these huge party chats and you know
that to me was just such a social system
i felt
i don't know if you agree no absolutely
i think uh
xbox came out of the gate with the best
sort of online ecosystem
and uh you know in my opinion and it is
just my opinion
they've never been topped like they came
out strong and they improved that
that uh product so well over the last 15
20 years now that um it is just
it's hard for me to imagine a better
ecosystem until someone makes it
definitely
yeah i'll figure on that man so yeah
that's
now we got into that i want to get your
career as far as getting it into the
industry because um
you know it's a little a little
different you know i would say
i was looking at your history and what
was kind of cool is you had some some
major stops in some other areas
before so i want to talk like before
journalism like
how was your career getting started and
then like what just specifically drew
you and inspired you to get started and
how did that
come about sure i mean i guess i can
just start back at the beginning
um
i think wow that's uh i mean
out of high school i did a couple years
at a community college ready to transfer
and um i got to the point where i was
super burned out
because i did i did my first two years
of college with my last two years of
high school congruently
wow there was this program that you
could do where basically my last two
years of high school
was at a community college um and so i
did that and i
you know i was super burned out so i
wanted to change and i had a buddy who
lived overseas
doing uh charity work for uh like a
community farm in in northern ireland
and he talked to me about that for a
while and i realized that's something
that i wanted to do
so you know i dropped everything went
over there for
a year um and then
you know did a lot of charity work with
the kids and and working on
sustainability
and and all that stuff uh and then i
came home and
i didn't have a you know i was i was 19
i didn't have a job i didn't have any
money because i used it all i don't know
if you know this but flying trans
atlantic is expensive
yeah so i didn't have any money i didn't
have a job i knew i loved video games i
knew
my intention was to actually get into
film um so i didn't have an intention to
work in the games industry because i
loved playing them why would i want to
you know uh but i uh you know i looked
around and i saw
i saw an ad for a qa tester at
electronic arts and i just
you know i happened to be lit i happened
to live in the bay area so i'm sure that
helped
right um so i saw an ad for qa tester
and applied
didn't get it but i got a call
from another department called cqc which
is consumer quality control if i
remember correctly
and basically you have qa who tests the
game for six to eight months
right it's ready to go that last week
before
it ships um you kick it over to cqc and
they're
what i would call like the white glove
test you know you make sure there's no
dust on it or anything
and oftentimes you find game breaking
bugs and stuff and then it goes back to
development
more often than not no though you're
like hey uh there's a there's a bug here
there's a problem
and it's adks as design known shipable
so they're like yeah don't worry about
that a little
so that's that's how i got started in
the game industry i
like a lot of people that i talked to in
the industry i came up through test
um and then you know my contract ended i
did nine months through a contract
firm with electronic arts and in order
to
a lot of companies do this in order to
make sure you're not a full-time
employee they have your contract on on
term limits so once nine months is off
uh
up you're three months off and then you
can come back and work it yep
because they don't want to give them no
benefits we know the game
i've come from that contract life
brother i know about that yeah yeah so
you was hustling you was hustling i was
looking for work
and if you were i could play video games
and work uh
you know i'm gonna do that uh
during my three months off i uh you know
i saw a spot at namco bandai which is in
san jose about
about 30 35 miles south of
redwood shores where electronic arts is
um so i applied to that and
got a job there and within a year i made
lead tester
and then a little while after that you
know i made associate producer
nice so i moved over to the other side
and did that job
i got to stop it for a second because
i'm a damn co-fan boy um
were you working on that's an
understatement yeah
you're working on anything on the tekken
series sir just just curious
so here's a fun thing i actually was
working on the mobile division
so namco namco in the us had nb and
i apologize because the the acronyms
have changed about six times since i
started
so at the time i think it was nbga namco
bandit games america
okay i worked for a subsidiary called
nnai namco networks america incorporated
which was the mobile division so
basically
we would uh create game mobile games and
i'm not talking like smartphone
because this was before that before yeah
this was when like uh paris hilton and
her t-mobile sidekick were all their age
oh god damn yeah we we would take like
pac-man
miss pac-man super pac dig dug galaga
like the big five
five along with some other smaller
things um
and we would port them to basically 3
000 handsets right and so my job as a as
a lead tester was my team would
would you know test out certain games on
on a couple hundred handsets at a time
then when i moved over my job uh was to
take those those reference games that we
made
on like five different cell phones and
then port them out to a very similar
cell phone so
i didn't touch i didn't touch the
console side gotcha i was i was all
mobile on a mobile side no
we were actually in different offices
but i believe they've since consolidated
that's awesome so then
like i said you're doing that now again
such a unique history
how did the transition to journalism
start like this is just so
botherless that is a pretty big change
yeah like you you've got
all these pockets of experience in these
different areas so how did that happen
uh that was a weird i actually remember
the exact moment
um uh so i was i was a producer i've
been doing that for three or four years
and honestly i was just
super bored the job um because it's
project management you know it's not
it's not as creative as as one might
think and yeah not as technical
yeah yeah and i'm a very technical
person i you know i like
i like grammar i like it uh you know i
like
i like all of the things that go into
creating something as best as it can be
but i'm also really creative right and i
didn't have an outlet for that because i
you know i was at a point in my life
where my creative outlet was like making
i almost swore i'm sorry
call of duty montages and stuff like
that
i was sitting in my cubicle eating lunch
out of tupperware
on my lunch break and i looked up and i
saw there was a
24-hour dark souls live stream by ign
i'm starring mcdonald and uh casey
i forget his name i'm sorry um he used
to be the old eic but
i'm sitting there watching it and i'm
like oh my god this game is right up my
alley
how do i not know about this game like
oh yeah and it's you know published by
namco banda and i'm like
and i realized at that moment that i was
in the wrong the wrong
field right because i get excited about
talking about games i get excited about
facts you know talking with people who
love games and
what i what i think or what i love about
games and
i'm sitting here looking at my
spreadsheets and i'm like man i'm in the
i'm in the wrong field
and i never considered myself a writer
so i spent the next
six months probably just reading
everything i could i read a lot of
joystick
i read a lot of ign wow read a lot of
kotaku read a lot of uh what was the
other one at the time
uh destructoid destructoid yes yes um so
i just read a lot
and then i actually had a friend who had
sort of the same aspirations and he
started his own site um
and and i was like hey i don't know what
i'm doing but can i like
can i like write something for you and
he goes hey
what do you want to write about and i'm
like well this dark souls game is coming
out can i write about that he goes yeah
you wanna do a review and i go
okay i don't know how to review again
but okay
uh somewhere we gotta start somewhere
freelance yeah so it came out
uh it came out i wanna say october 15th
it was two weeks before halloween i
think
uh so it came out in october uh and then
i played it
i beat it and wrote a review in the
following two weeks and published it on
halloween and it was like seven thousand
words
uh so i had no idea how to write
and like i didn't know grammar that well
i still like misplaced where to put the
apostrophe
start brother that was your story so it
was a crash course you know
um so i just i basically kicked the
tires a little bit on it and figured
out how to write for an audience what to
say
uh get a feel and here's the thing man
it's like that was
2000 it was 2011.
so i've only been doing this for eight
nine years now
yeah so anybody could pick it up now
and run with it and it takes a little
practice and it takes a little time
but you train yourself and it's just
like it's just like working out right is
you building up your muscles
absolutely as long as you are constantly
reading constantly
like trying to improve the craft and
looking things like imitation
like if you see something that's good
why is it good
read it so that's what i did
and then namco was going through a very
transitional period at the time
uh budgets were being slashed and all
that and
my boss came up to me and was like hey
you know uh you know we're gonna reduce
some workforce here
um and i and at that point in the
conversation i kind of
had a feeling like i didn't really want
to do this anymore um
i had a pretty heart-to-heart
conversation with her and was like look
i i just i don't
i don't think this is what i want to do
i'm good at it and i'll continue to be
to be a producer for you but um you know
my goal is to not do this
as a career fair enough fair enough and
then i got laid off
[Laughter]
did you feel that way since you feel
that way let's transition you right into
this other place
exactly don't know what they're doing in
the workforce
i got laid off but in hindsight it was a
blessing because i got
you know a modest severance package like
i didn't make great money but i got
something to hold you down it gave me
about a year
of eating top ramen and just getting
high on my rent
bro the struggle was real red i could
feel it
yeah it gave me about a year to really
like
dig in and be like look if i'm going to
do this i got to do this full time right
like
and this is not i do not recommend going
this path like don't quit your job
don't don't give up your security your
safety net your security blanket it's
it's not smart
and i don't advocate for it but it
allowed me to spend the year
that i needed yes to really kind of like
turn myself into somebody that could
write for an audience and create content
and uh figure out how to speak because i
uh you know i was
always very an extroverted person but i
didn't know how
to effectively communicate my thoughts
and it just took like a lot of reading
and it took a lot of
um it took a lot of reading other
people's work people who are better
writers than i was people who are still
better writers than i am
and and even beyond just the ability to
write it's the ability to think right
it's like how do you communicate what
you're trying to say in a way to make
someone understand
understand it exactly this is tremendous
i don't want to gloss over it because
you know obviously i know you're
advocating for for people to give up
security but at the same time
what is commendable is you realizing
internally
what you were doing while you were
comfortable financially
wasn't where your heart was and the
minute you saw that dark souls thing the
minute you saw it like
you were something inside you picked up
and said okay that excites me
that's what i want to do so there's
value in that right because at the end
of the day
you know you do have to follow your
passions if it's you know
feasible you know say you definitely
follow your passions and one thing
that's cool is like i said you took that
time because you had the time
to then build yourself up get that skill
set popping
and then make yourself presentable so
then how did that transition now
into ign opportunity like
popping off yeah yeah so that that was a
long period and um i almost quit
actually i almost quit writing because i
just i couldn't i couldn't see a path
it's hard i couldn't see a path how to
make money how to make a career out of
this
and like i was getting the point where i
was borrowing money from my parents
at that point in order to like just try
to stave off having to get a job at
safeway
and i applied i applied to grocery
stores and target and like i was just
looking for a paycheck while i tried to
continue to pursue this um
but like no one would hire me like he
said i had too much experience to stock
shelves don't you hate all right can we
sideball one i work out like i can lift
boxes
like that is in my skills you're
overqualified
dude i i feel you're paying on that that
that's that's they feel like if you're
like way over qualified you're just
going to be like an extremely temporary
worker that is going to leave in like a
month
so that's what they said too it's like
they're looking for somebody who's
you know more long-term yeah but it's
still stock shelves let's
point that out i don't know right like
it still sucks though right because it's
like damn like i i
qualify for this i i i'm telling you i
want this
yeah you are saying no you have your
skill set is too
immense for this i i think it's more
just like hey
it's the second you get he touched on it
perfectly the second you get a better
opportunity you're gone and then we're
gonna have to train
let's be real like a lot of times in
that situation too
uh you might take their job so they try
and have you in the in the left position
yeah in a couple years
oh he's overqualified when when i mess
up you know they might look at him
i wasn't gunning for shift manager
i just wanted to stop eating top ramen
like what do you what do you do at that
point and what i basically did was like
i
as much as i hate to to donate i
borrowed money from my folks
um you know and then i i did everything
i could to try to get
a job fortunately at that point i had
something resembling chops i want to say
and i i started doing the the most
important thing you can do if you're
looking to get into the industry which
is
outreach yeah it's it's networking it's
outreach it's finding where the
opportunities are
i'll be honest there are people who will
do this job as good or better than i can
but they didn't they didn't reach out
right like they don't know where to go
and where to look for that
so we always you know tell the we always
preach that because it's just like
there's a lot of you know individuals
that like kind of want to
maybe feel like they're a little bit
like shy in terms of like being around
crowds and stuff they don't like going
to these events and stuff
and i always be telling people like
you'd be surprised how many doors you
open if you go to those practices you go
to those e3s when you can't
not working brother but continue like
you're dropping some some gems as far as
you know that whole um networking and
just make yourself
available shout out to anonymous get
that neck gator feed the wolves continue
yeah yeah so at that point i just needed
a body of work to show people that i
knew what i was doing so i started
writing i i did what i i also don't
advocate for i started writing for free
i didn't know what else to do i don't
think you should but
you know i'll be uh i'll be it would be
a lie to say that it didn't benefit me
because it got me
got me by lines on on websites so um i
think everyone's creative
you know uh creations i guess are
valuable and you shouldn't just give
them away but
at some point you are gonna need a
byline to show somebody to show editor
so how do you work i started writing for
a site called xbla fans okay which was
uh excuse me
i had coffee oh that's so good i started
writing for xbla fans
uh as you know just a contributor no
salary anything
kind of wrote for them for a year
started taking on more and more things
which will
go into a next point i have but like
graphic design started doing like
weekly columns and eventually you know
worked my way up
like worked my way up i eventually had
been doing it so long
that you know they started giving me
like a small weekly stipend and it was
it was nothing but it was like it was
the my first job like somebody paid me
to do this
and that was the moment right like that
would you finally see some form of
income
if someone will pay me to do this
another person will pay me to do this
exactly
then i kind of smelled blood in the
water and just started i hit up one
culture i started writing reviews for
them
um they're like a uk based yes i know
exactly where they are yeah they're very
good
and then i started doing what um
what i think the next and most important
thing is is actually looking for people
and looking for contact information so
i started hitting up editors everywhere
like i applied
i applied for a weekend editor position
at joystick
let's go joystick yeah i think at the
time it was alexander
swalinsky was the weekend editor and he
was looking to hire somebody out
um i saw you know basically all these
different opportunities
just just trying to get the email
address of somebody that
would give me money to write for them to
write for them no bro yeah you're moving
yeah and ign put out a call for
freelancers and i
checked it out and uh you know i read
through the thing i filled out the
application and they're like
we need a writing sample please write
these three stories in in the uh style
of ign
what i did was basically i read probably
85
ign news stories that afternoon style
did your homework
you did the research studied no they
were looking for
uh applied got got brought on as a
regular freelancer and at that point you
know you get you get a small amount of
money for every article you write not
from you you go get these articles so i
mean i came in in the same freelancer
class as
seth macy who's uh the executive editor
of commerce at ign
now um there's a couple other people
over at ign that came up sort of around
the same time i did in the same class so
it would i always hear andrew golfer was
always like that was a good class
a lot of us like that draft yeah yeah
so um i i wrote freelance for about a
year and
while i was doing news stories i was
just like hey you know you need any
other thing
any other work or anything and that that
brings me to the second point that i
wanted to make if you're trying to break
it in which is uh
make yourself invaluable yep
right there are a lot of jobs in this
world that people don't want to do
but they need to be done and if you are
the type of person that will say
uh you know not sell yourself short but
if you're the type of person that will
say
i will do that job or i will take that
for the team
that was transcription work i don't know
if you guys are familiar with do a lot
of transcription
but it's it sucks it is the worst
bro we did one and it was
very difficult very difficult could
please talk about that
so transcription is basically somebody
does an interview
45 minutes with a developer and then
they need to figure out what was said so
that they can go back and pull quotes
and information so what that means is
and nowadays there are services that do
this that are fairly cheap
but what that means is you know five
years ago i was the guy who was like
somebody was asking if you're doing
transcription works
yeah yeah i'll do transcription work i'm
a master
i'm a master whatever look at that
initiative look at that initiative
so basically i you know i think i
endeared myself to some of the
that crew by just being like hey i will
transcribe whatever you want and it was
crazy it was like eight hours of audio
that they needed done in a week because
colin moriarty went and interviewed
everybody at sony santa monica so it was
like 12
interviews with with you know 12
different developers over eight hours
wow so you know i'd spend a week just
transcribing and it sucked and i hate it
but i got a lot of money out of it and
you know i got my name on people's
radars yeah so
at that point i just got started getting
a lot more transcription work while i
was writing news
um so they kind of all fell into
into place next time an editorial job
opened up they're like well we got this
guy who's busting his
butt um and you know he he does work for
us that
and he does it cheap that nobody else
wants to do
so i got an interview i probably only
heard the cheap
word how much my price
tag was 100 of the reason
i got an interview i showed up in a full
suit oh yeah the full suit
yeah yeah um and you know did the
interview and the rest is history it's
this history brother listen man
tremendous story first of all the
determination
i love that i love like you said what's
invaluable is making yourself
invaluable or i'm saying just and
totally putting yourself out there
taking initiative even when the
opportunity
necessarily you know they were asking
you to do something like you just
hey i could do that i could jump in you
know so i can give that a shot and just
kind of
learning on the fly based on your
initiative like
that is super cool and then look at you
man ign editor
out here moving and shaking one of the
time
out here a lot of a lot of people would
have done that one
just one transitional work and be like
yeah this is for the birds i'm done with
this i'm not doing this ever again
yeah make yourself reliable and show
that you do good work and even if you
don't care about what you're doing
treat it it's the most important thing
in the world exactly man that dad
again so many gems there a lot of things
we can pick so i want to get into also
you know where the realm obviously most
of us were familiar with you
is obviously the amazing podcast
unlocked
you know what i'm saying so shout out to
the team the legendary ryan mccaffrey
who we've had in the realm
salute riot of course you know what i'm
saying lady miranda are you lost
on recently yes of course oh god
and of course destiny game by destiny
brendan man so like
you know obviously one of the top xbox
podcasts
and um just always tune in you know
every week
sorry i missed you because i i took your
spot that day
well by your favorite words man no
worries no no it was the opportunity
yeah i'm glad i'm glad that you were on
there i'm glad we were able to get
get you on um the weird thing about
unlocked is these days as we're all
getting higher in the company we have
more responsibilities and more things to
do
so like half the year i'm planning e3
and gamescom and i just can't
i can't be on so yeah i think your
game's coming that week right
you're doing that probably probably yeah
what is time anymore dude like
this year is it was it yesterday was it
last week or was it
turn around tomorrow's like e3's next
week what
right i wouldn't be surprised salute to
you on that because um
again tremendous podcast had a fantastic
time
you know so what led to that opportunity
of becoming a panelist on
a lot uh i you know i don't really know
i can't remember it was a gradual
transition uh
ryan and i kind of hit it off
immediately as soon as i joined the
company nice
um because he and i both love metallica
you know i saw the concert picks i did
see that continue yeah
we're both xbox and me coming from like
xbla fans and really that xbla ecosystem
and um you know microsoft being my my
main
console like we shared stories so we hit
it off a lot
um but you know like any any junior in a
role right like i was waiting for an
opportunity absolutely
and he kept asking you know somebody was
out hey do you want to be on unlocked
sure yeah why not
um and then you know over time all the
good people left
and then oh my gosh and then i got a
spot
i guess the moral of the story is
patience
you are way too humble outlast
everywhere
he's like sooner or later people's
neither gonna get fired or they're gonna
get bored and leave
oh wait persistence is everything yeah a
savage
no but one thing on this show man i
always love your takes you know saying
definitely to it besides ryan you're
definitely one of my friends on the show
very balanced
always give things from dang i think it
comes from your experience also you know
i'm saying you know being
also with a lot of these uh companies
and stuff in gaming
it gives you a different unique
perspective but i would definitely want
to shout you out there
um real quick so i'll just get a couple
checks i got one more set of questions
for him yeah we have a phantom kraken
with the two dollar super chat no hit
the like button yes please hit that like
button
please and we have makai 28 with the
five dollar super chat uh pl
please say something brother please um
and then we have echelon 7 the darkness
with the five dollar super chat
shout out to kings man shout out to
brandon aka lord tyrell peace to the
lord stan
i like that lord very game of thrones
kind of i'm kind of happy yeah yeah
caught a fire last night for this i like
that
lord of flowers forever
it's cool it's a good last name i like
it margery tyrell
good morning lords this show is my mama
makes
yeah so look man um another thing like i
want to touch on obviously
we did the unlocked thing but um just
what's pretty like i said admirable
about you
is just you know obviously you're
telling your catalog but like you said
that work ethic you know what i'm saying
so obviously i got a chance
to work alongside you e3 i believe it
was 2018 metro
exodus you know what i said i saw you
2018
that was 25 years ago man doesn't it
feels doesn't it feel so long since we
could actually go to conventions and do
normal stuff
like this media is crazy but um yeah man
i came across you you know it was it was
tremendous and i know you got so much
going on but i remember
like just how hard you worked even
during that time you took the time to
stop
talk to me it was really cool very cool
experience and um
i just again what helped cultivate
that work ethic and again just a little
bit more advice
for people that are striving to get into
this industry that they love so much
oh man uh i mean i don't i don't know
like as far as
i don't want to make it sound like a
cop-out or anything but like where does
work ethic come from i guess
uh i'm kind of a competitive person i
just kind of want to be the best at
everything that i do which
is like everyone says that but um
i don't know where they come from that's
dr bro i'm not going to
just gloss over this
i've always had drive i think probably
upbringing right like at all but
everything in our lives boils down to
like mom
said something once in the kitchen or
you know
uh i remember i didn't have the toy that
the other kid had and like i'll never
forget that fist and all that so
um yeah i don't know drive comes
wherever
for everybody where you know it comes
from the same spot just sort of a
collection of your experiences growing
up
what about what about advice again for
people trying to really
break in this industry man they're
gamers they they've got that passion
you know what what would you say to
those girls guys so it's it's tough
right because these days it's a
different beast i feel like i got in
right at the end of what
everyone sort of considers the sort of
the old age of journalism or
to be clear i don't consider myself a
journalist i didn't go to school for
that
i am an entertainment writer and a
critic
um but i i got in right at the end where
like
the written word was the oh yeah the
chief medium of our industry right
that's not the case anymore we are if
not 50 50 we are more video focused than
we've ever been in the past
yes um so you know you're gonna have to
learn
those skills right and i i
don't tell anyone this but i found a
cracked version of uh
adobe premiere exclusive software
related
i don't know what you're talking about
tell us all you can relate i
don't tell anybody but we're live
[Laughter]
i have spent uh several hundred dollars
on a fine adobe project since
so you know i i feel like i i've made it
up but you've had your pen and sister
yeah yeah you know don't learn adobe
premiere learn how to capture
learned how to use youtube uh which is
still something that i'm trying to
continue to learn it feels like that
algorithm changes every day every time
it really does so uh
i guess what i'm trying to say is you
need to be a well-rounded person
uh as far as uh not person employee is
what is
what you're offering people you need to
figure out how to write figure out how
to write for an audience
figure out uh the video side yes there
is a social media element to this game
as well um you know visibility
is important it's why i have a twitter
because i'm not a huge fan of social
media but
you know it is a job requirement now
absolutely wow
you need to check that out i mean ign
doesn't require me to have a twitter but
realistically you need to be on twitter
absolutely yeah
that's where so much of that news
happens and things break so
um you know it's crazy brandon like
the only time like when i know
something's really went big
is when i see it on facebook it's like
oh god
it's it's big enough it's jumped over to
facebook already
i didn't get the memo man i got like
three or four masks yeah you didn't get
the bible
i didn't get the memo brandon
yo but i'm telling you like once you
feel that that looks crazy
absolutely
he said it last week he did say that he
was born
i love it but but i'm going to tell you
social media
i was like it looks like i'm part of the
backpack yes yes
shout out to the halloween version of
the lords today very fashionable watch
out next thing you know people are going
to ask
are you guys selling that on tv
hey for the right bucks i can't
moving along man oh my god but again
dude tremendous advice tremendous
history man what a cool
journey very inspirational i love the
grind brother
but anyway we've got to ask the question
that we ask
all those in the round lord
i need your top five video games or
franchises
of all time no pressure
none at all one better one better be the
legend of zelda no pressure
you know what had you asked me two years
ago it wouldn't have been the legend of
zelda but breath of the wild oh my god
one of the best members of ign i'm sorry
sorry ryan with this choice lord brandon
has solidified himself
as one of the best panel members salute
breath of the wild go switch coming in
hot let's put the switch coming in hot
in the chat y'all put it up brandon you
know what time
continue unbiased
switch is doing some really smart things
really good
um but okay we're gonna top top five
let's
zelda let's go halo obviously clearly
um god what a question uh
anything it's not a franchise or a game
but anything
from soft makes in the soulsborne arena
and speaks to me on another level that
was right all right you you've made up
for that breath of the wild
all right your repeat man i already put
you on the never invite again list
again uh i'm gonna i'm gonna hit one
from every major platform yeah
what i got i got i got zelda i got halo
yeah halo you got any the from
forum software any like souls kind of
games yeah it's tough
four and five are hard because i i have
really eclectic tastes
uh as far as video games like i'll i'll
be really into strategy tactics based
games
that's my thing like lately all i'm all
i'm build or all i'm playing is just
like
fantasy tactics games like the dungeon
of ebolic and druid stone
and games you've never heard of and on
pc and really loving them and then you
know
event season comes and or or uh sorry
holiday season comes and i'm playing
like triple a games and loving those
as well so but what resonated with you
personally even if it's not like just
something that you like man
i in that game i just can't stop like
this is my heart
i got it i got it and you guys are gonna
make fun of me overwatch
thank you i love that continue that i'm
gonna clip that at least it's a great
game
cognito yeah uh it's actually
you guys are gonna make fun of me but
it's like spike
has it hey no i actually had like a
little thing for smite for probably
about two or three months
later and i realized no one plays out on
consoles so i had to like backtrack
that's why spike little red that's
actually a really fun game
it is super fun it's a moba right
but it's not the reason i never liked uh
dota or league of legends uh i hope
miranda's yeah i was just about to say
don't let miranda hear that
i love you don't be mad at me for me
um the reason i never got into top down
clicky click stuff it's because
it feels like i click i like that
it feels like micromanaging to me
whereas i is third person
uh sort of elevated camera yes or
three quarters i submit or not isometric
but three-quarters over the shoulder
style um and you're you're really you're
this character and you're running around
and you're you know you get into the
jungle and you can't see anything around
you so
you're going to get ambushed and jumped
by like loki who comes from nowhere
and it is also mythology based and i
actually okay big fantasy nerd
most of fantasy comes from like
mythology and antiquity and all that
like that's just kind of where it gets a
start
i love it um so totally resonate with
that
i've been playing it for seven years and
i probably
have two hundred thousand hours into it
i don't know
wow what i like about smite is just like
it's so strategic and it doesn't look
strategic
like yeah it's a legit strategy game and
it is
there's also a lot of skill shots like
you actually have to aim your abilities
in it which uh i like much better than
like clicking on the enemy and pressing
that they're pressing that yeah
yeah when you're positioning ultimately
you might lose yeah when you're poseidon
and you summon the kraken there's a
circle on the ground and you move that
circle where you want it to go and then
it pops up
right giant monster comes out of the
ground and it's
it is dope i fell in love with it the
second i played it in beta
and uh it has been there at like 102
characters now or something like that
you know like what what i like about
certain games is
is when you play certain games you have
to play with like the
at least the high tier character the
biggest scary because
you got to know what they're going to
throw at you just as much as they got to
know what you're going to throw at them
so
you know when you're facing beside
you're like yo i gotta i got to keep in
mind
you might summon that thing on me you
know i mean it's the same thing with any
moba right like the the most important
thing is knowing what your character
does the second most important thing is
knowing what your opponent's doing
yes right so learning 100 gods is
daunting
i think i think smite's on board is
really really good to get new players
into it and that again that camera angle
makes it much more accessible so sprite
is gonna probably anchor my number five
spot for the rest of my life until it
goes down
nice um i'm having trouble with a four
so maybe
maybe somewhere in this conversation
it'll pop up i mean you could pick
something recent maybe for
like something maybe this year that 80s
80s all right let's go that was yeah
because i put that
that was your gif for the for the show
yeah yeah yeah
i'm sorry are we are we on the jiff side
of the fence oh yeah i forgot
i apologies
[Laughter]
anyway tremendous five brother and the
last question oh the favorite console of
all time
no pressure past the present 360. whoa
i knew he was going to say that
approved that was the first time i could
play video games with my friends and we
weren't sitting on the same couch
actually
changing if if you're actually logical
about your favorite system most
people would say the 360.
it really did change the game like the
360 is started the current the modern
era of consoles of console absolutely
well
it connects you it allows you to do
whatever you're looking to do whether it
be media or entertainment
and things it it changed everything like
completely agree but
it shut down the whole social dynamic it
changed
with the mario film
because before we go to each other's
houses
history brother oh my god i can't can't
even imagine like i said just i get the
drive and
of course you got to hang out for a
little bit i don't know how we're doing
all the time sort of
yes okay okay cool just want to make
sure so we got to get into
last week's poll results they are in
until the people have spoken
chat is laughing okay he said god dammit
king
last week's full results are in it the
people have spoken to the question
with both next-gen consoles steadily
approaching and now in the hands of the
media
which specific technical aspect of
next-gen consoles has you most excited
the winner of the four-way ilp poll at
44
was the 60 frames per second and pushing
to 120 frames per second
games grew coming in at second at 33
was raw cpu and gpu power coming in that
third at a very close 16 percent
was nvme ssd load times
and in last place at five percent was
the petty lords
i don't care too many people are excited
for paid remasters and back compat
launch games
shout out to all those in the room lord
sovereign the frames have won sir
as well they should the fraps listen if
you're a console gamer
consoles have always traditionally been
built to to focus on
picture quality right picture quality
resolution
you know they sell the selling brand new
tvs kind of goes hand in hand with
consoles
this first time we've had cpus in these
consoles that can really
realistically push these type of frame
rates you know we've seen it
we've seen it here and there in certain
games over over this past generation but
never anything that you can say like
it's almost a new baseline right
although you know some of these
cross-gen games aren't really hitting
that but
i think as we go further into the ninth
generation it's gonna be that so that's
exciting because
that's the one place where consoles
never really could touch pc
right and we're sort of we're sort of
blurring that line
yeah absolutely man yes we gonna get
into it man
get these topics poppin actually one
super chat then we leave the vessel
we have simon brandy with the five pound
super chat great show
brandon got to get king david on
unlocked when phil spencer is on next
not with these suits he got
doesn't have a lot of free time exactly
they love you guys brandon is a top
bloke too
ah salute salute you already know that
love for freddie what else we got
we got one more that jumped in fastback
iron loads are always fire playing watch
dogs legion today on one x now soon on
series x but on my no
shame 4k tcl preferred
i like how you put that
let me go ahead and uh you know the
lords want to give back a little bit so
this one right here i'm gonna do a
couple giveaways on the uh the members
in the patreon but
right now i'm gonna do a giveaway on the
actual chat all right and i'm gonna ask
you guys a question
let's go every year the lords do
a bend the knee on the video game awards
yes who won last year first one
yeah that's good that's good yeah that's
a good one
i don't even remember
i only said it because it was already in
the chat
just just to clarify you did win it
because i don't remember either
why would you ask that question because
obviously i could just ask you guys
oh my god uh have we determined the
winner yes yes
none of your business won all right none
of your business salute man make sure
you hit them up
you know what i'm saying yeah shitty
thank you for voting for me but i did
not win so i'll be killing the polls man
the king no i did not win so look man we
moving all we got we all set at it with
that one
yeah yeah all right none of your
business please contact addict and his
dms on twitter
none of your business went i was like
what that
yeah we're folding our own giveaways
yeah so look man let's get right into it
hot topic right now this week that it
dropped down um halo infinite
losing another top director man shout
out to lord jason schreiber who we've
had in the realm before
he's one of the first to break the story
yeah chris lee he um he had over so
oversaw a production at 343 no longer
working at it
and um he was the second top director in
the project to leave in the last two
years
and then basically um before that was
tim
longo and then mary olsen and um
yeah basically that the at the time when
they were replaced by you know by chris
lee
the vision and the production of the
game went to him so now you know chris
lee made a statement
he stepped back from infinite and
looking forward at future opportunities
i believe in the team and i'm confident
they will deliver a great
game and now is a good time for me to
step
away king is laughing um with the second
director
now leaving a hell with it let's start
this off with uh lord lord brandon like
how confident
are you in halo infinite's direction and
then
the second part is like how do you think
they should handle
you know release especially i think phil
recently made some comments
about hinting potentially just just
hinting out
separating multiplayer and single player
so where are you at with this whole halo
infinite thing lord brandon
that team knows how to make a video game
that team knows how to make a halo game
um i believe that uh
the delay is going to be for the better
we we know that they brought in new
directors right like we knew what was
going to happen they brought in a little
bit more experience to
you know lend that veteran status to get
to get
over the finish line but i think uh what
they showed off
probably in the reaction that they got
probably justified the fact that they
need
a considerable amount more time so i'm
not expecting to see halo until like
holiday 2021
but um i still think that
you know when that game comes out it's
gonna do
what we all hope it's gonna do right
right which is reset the brand because
i don't know how you guys feel but
personally i feel like halo isn't the
name that it used to be
yeah you know i i don't think four was
as good as three it's hard for
anything in the halo series to be three
for me i mean i love
you know dst but four and then five i
just thought was a bad game
if i'm being honest so i'm looking for
infinite to reset
uh to reset that brand and make it
relevant again because
you know guys our age like we know what
halo is
you talk to a kid who plays fortnight
and they're like oh you mean that that
super soldier game thanks
so i am not a hundred percent confident
with where the game is now right but you
know give it another year and i think
that we're going to see something
in holiday 2021 season that you know
a big re-reveal of that game coming out
by then
the xbox series x will have its feet
under it right you know
development time is our development
expertise on the console has been
building and building and post launch
they're going to get just a ton of data
from users
so you know i'm confident that holiday
next season we're going to see that game
turn into something special
but fair enough i want to double down
though as far as
uh company structure right yeah and just
you know this movement that we're seeing
like this is it's kind of i don't say
it's i've never seen it before but it is
a lot of moving and shaking
up top before release like you know
does that signify a red flag to you like
what does that signify that
you know it's changing ownership and
then
the second part again you know about
this
would you be okay if they said hey
single player separate
you know kind of thing like how how are
you with that as well you do you mean
like
releasing single player and dropping
multiplayer later or vice versa
selling themselves okay um
yeah yeah so tackling the single
multiplayer uh thing first i'm fine with
it i think if they release
halo halo infinite multiplayer as a
standalone thing that you play with your
friends
that's totally fine i don't think that
hurts anybody okay um
so i think breaking it out is is i mean
we've seen call of duty do it right kind
of kind of
i mean it is all one package but those
are very different experiences now
right there are you know the majority of
the people pick it up for multiplayer
and then i don't have numbers on this
but i feel like equal numbers pick it up
for the single player and zombies
um as far as the studio culture goes
um you know when a project is coming to
the finish line and
there's something wrong with it there
are there are fires to be put out there
are
there are there are certain intangibles
that you only get by experience right
you only get with veteranship um you've
shipped a ton of games you know
how to just get things across the finish
line what this reads to me is they've
obviously brought in new directors i
think it was only
a matter of time before you see the the
old leadership team sort of like take a
step back
right um and this was probably planned
in a transition right and it's just now
it's at a point where
they feel that the a is either far
enough removed or they have a better
handoff now they can they can move him
back and and
and put him back i think he's still in
the back he's still with microsoft yeah
he's still a mark he's just not with
three foot three
right so they're at a point now where
you know it just makes sense to like
pass the baton
because like i said you need that
veteran leadership to come in
and um start putting out fires start
saying like okay
this is what we need to get to this is
where we're at and then there are some
hard decisions that are going to need to
be made
and i think that's where that that sort
of experience is going to lend itself
well so
um i actually think it's a good thing i
think i think the shake-up
is a good thing because nobody wants to
release a sub-par game you saw what
happened with crackdown
right that dwindled for too long
and i think there wasn't any like
serious decisions made for there and
they released it as it is
i i'm of i'm of the opinion there you
don't want to release something if it's
not going to be a great experience but
there is also an understanding that like
at some point you just got to recoup
your losses
yeah facts facts so i i think all the
shuffling is good
and i'm totally happy with them breaking
them out no doubt no doubt solved with a
super chat they would get addicts or
thoughts
uh that we have we have slo-mo backslap
with the five-dollar super chat brandon
how often have you seen a project demo
multiple lead directors and the game
still to
turn out to be a success
[Laughter]
lord addict chris lee man
he's uh he's moving on and uh there's a
little shake-up going on how how we
feeling about halo if this is your game
you know all the lore you probably most
passionate halo person i know
what's up how you feeling man i feel
like
with this particular thing now i'm right
there with brandon
i've come to the point where i got zero
hope in this game almost like
maybe it's like 20 maybe not zero but
it's just like they've showed me
incompetence more and more
i think you know a lot of people want to
say that 343 isn't a good studio and i i
don't i'm not necessarily there i think
maybe it's poorly managed at this point
and i think maybe
they they had
a skill that they shouldn't have had a
scale on like
they they wanted the game to function
like this but it wasn't realistic to
function like this and i think they made
a new engine to make it function like
that
and i don't make maybe you know
something happened with the engine maybe
having a hard time optimizing the engine
i don't know i'm not at three four three
right but i feel like three four three
is salvageable
okay i just don't know what the
management is
so like to me i feel like this this
chris thing chris lee leaving
is is just shifting people out yeah
uh i i think that it was neither him
stay there
or he get demoted i mean he leaves there
he gets demoted
and i feel like you would rather do a
lighter move than just get demoted
because clearly he was the lead over
there
i think he was the person right under
barney wasn't he i believe yeah i
believe so
i think he's the director yeah i think
loki
you know jason or no joseph what what's
his name
joseph statten and joseph i think he got
his job now
so i think you know obviously there
can't be two people
in charge like that over there so i
think that there's like look man
you know clearly and plus we can't be we
have to be realistic this is a business
right um someone's getting blamed for
what's being gone down
right now factual let me ask you this
though
i want not to cut you i got to ask you
because i want your opinion
what do you feel about them separating
it
if that cause remember phil just did an
interview and they asked him
you know now in the beginning prior to
when he thought it was going to release
that wasn't on the table right but
actually
it was as he said that it's a
possibility how do you feel about that
running
i'm not okay with it but i was told like
a year and a half it was going to be
separated
okay so i already kind of had that
thought in my head i don't think that's
a good idea
i think that you know they both need to
be get to
uh they both need to be together right
because this isn't like
fortnite or something like that this is
halo like this is one of their pillars
if you make them in separate like it
would be different like a beta
but it's not a beta they're talking
about releasing the game
first off there's gonna be the
narratives that they uh that they can
release half
half in games because the game pass you
know that narrative is gonna contain
if they release the single player
multiplayer and then later they release
the other one
people are going to automatically say
are you going to give me half-baked
games because you have game pass and
that's what you're going to fall back on
right right uh i think that this is what
this is their pillar this isn't just
some
you know some what's what i'm looking
for something that they just did this
isn't like a sequel to a game that just
came out
this is literally what made the xbox
brand what it is today
and how to interrupt your destiny news
flash cat daddy said
lucy blade is back at the recast it goes
long and get it
sorry that was a random i saw a destiny
guy he's doing you in service right now
he said go
get it cause it's this thank you cat
daddy you are the man that is love from
a clan mate continue
so you know i think what's going to
happen is
i don't know how much reach
bonnie ross has at the studio i'm not
there right i don't know if maybe she's
just a figurehead
uh because i think she is the founder of
that studio isn't she
so i i don't like can they i mean it's
owned by microsoft obviously they can
get rid of
i just don't know what they would right
you know she might be just
you know the executive person that that
leads it all right but she has no saying
what goes on the system
uh in the actual game itself she might
be in charge of everything
we don't have enough information but you
know when it comes to halo as a whole
i i don't care if the thing has to get
pushed to 2022 because yeah but
it's just like this is not your regular
game like
explain to me you know i definitely want
you know brandon's opinion on this
to me it feels like coalition has done a
better job evolving gears then
the 343 has had three attempts this is
the third attempt
and they still haven't done it well um
yeah
i mean yeah i mean argument brandon made
some good points right in reference to
their entries right we we know about you
know we said that the consensus that
when i was unlocked i told him i was
like
my consensus like four had a great
campaign but didn't necessarily have
the good you know a good multiplayer
where five universally people did not
like the campaign i felt for the most
part
and the multiplayer was solid we already
know about the master chief collection
the
debacle you know 343 hasn't had you know
the strongest
out the gate you know what i'm saying as
far as you know their relationship with
this franchise i want to get
i'm sorry i wouldn't let you finish up
then we gotta get solvent my question to
you is
do you think that let's say we have a
magical ball
then it's like halo is going to be bad
dude because of all this stuff because
right now what we're seeing that's what
it's looking like it's looking like that
they went over their head they have no
clue
how they're going to take about this
game like do you think it would do
more damage to the halo brand to come
out like that
or to just try to rebrand it and and to
and to take as much away from it as
possible and rebuild onto it which might
add another year or two onto the
development cycle which you know it's
not gonna happen
but do you think it would be more
beneficial to take the time to correct
the mistake or to release it now
and hope they can fix it later brandon
it's a good question but you're insane
if you think they're going to rebrand it
oh no
they're not doing it to me no no
yeah yeah here's the thing is the name
halo is more profitable than any
mechanic in halo itself right like that
that idea is is what sells i mean hey
it's the name it's the the
the spirit of it so um i think
you're right 100 halo internet needs to
be a banger
like it cannot it cannot come out
lukewarm it cannot come out
and be like a solid seven it's not it's
got to be at night
it's gonna be that solid seven bombs you
know i will say one
thing how they had they took on the
bethesda project you know they got all
those studios
i feel like it's a little less on halo
than it used to be now it's still a lot
on halo because
halo is halo halo you know definitely
revolutionized all of online gaming
especially first-person market and
particularly on the on the console
but i do think since they have you know
they have stuff like doom
they have stuff like the elder scrolls i
think it's a little bit off of halo
right because now
they don't have to rely at all entirely
on it i understand
but i think throwing out the halo brand
and hope it sticks is definitely not a
good idea
to see what's gonna happen i'm sorry
brad good to see you
no no you're 100 right like they need to
take all the time they can to get this
right and
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna pretend that
i know the
structure of 343 or microsoft or who
calls the shots or who says what
i don't know how it works but there's
there's like hundreds of years of
combined halo development experience
between those two organizations i
believe they can do it
i believe they can get it right if it
takes two years it takes two years
but if you release a bad halo game oh
that's the end of halo yeah
i agree i agree solve you want to get
super chats in europe
uh we have the grounded gamer jay funds
valley bay area 49ers stand up let's go
tonight
the 10-year halo infinite plan doesn't
feel like the right move
uh and doesn't point to being a solid
campaign experience just look at
destiny's campaign oh lord
slander i mean that's not but i i i what
you mean
i would agree when it comes to the
destiny campaign one of the things that
i don't like about it i've said this a
million times it just feels like
the world is built for for the
multiplayer engagements right
the world built around it doesn't feel
lived in in a way that i want from
like a campaign story so that's why you
know
it doesn't draw my attention um then we
have fandom kraken with the two dollar
super chat leadership at coalition had
rod ferguson 343 bonnie ross
i can't remember but i don't think rob
fergus i don't think that's a fair
comparison like
i feel like a comparison with rob
ferguson would be chris lee isn't it
like what he wasn't like that
overall the city he was just a director
wasn't he like i can't remember he left
a long time ago
um but i just i'm a huge halo fan i just
want the friend the brand tries to do
better
and you know me incognito was convinced
that microsoft
i was i was giving microsoft props just
for delaying it in general
because i was convinced that they was
going to use this as a sacrifice of lamb
just so they could say they have halo as
a launch title yeah if actually
we did think that we think it was coming
hell of high water man soft
where we at man but this whole chris lee
didn't shake up with yet i mean
it it's just i'm glad that it happened
now because to be honest the moment
joseph stanton came back and the moment
pierre
uh hands came back that shift half that
happened internally we just didn't see
it
right um so it's just a matter of it
playing out now the way the way it
actually happened when they when they
moved in you know
when these guys came on they sort of
took over and it was a matter of making
that transition look as smooth as
possible with as little friction as
possible
again so we're not here uh talking about
you know what it would mean
um but but like brandon said i think
it's a good thing i think they have the
people in place now that they want to
sort of take this
you know past the finish line right um
what that product looks like again
you know there's been speculation oh do
they can it completely no they're not
going to count it completely we're going
to get a halo game
and they're going to try they're going
to try to mold what's there to to
as good a product as they possibly can
make it
but i think that's what it is um but i
do think that now
in terms of management in terms of you
know managing the time managing the team
and getting it across the finish line i
think they're in a much better place
than they have been
so that's that's great now to the
question about separating yeah where you
at with that
i'm at the point really i i'm for it 100
and i'm for them and i'm for them
putting the multiplayer out first
because they stated that multiplayer is
going to be free to play the
multiplayer's gonna be free to play it
is going to be this humongous thing that
is going to try to put halo
like brandon said it's not it's not what
it was
once was how do you do that well the
moment they announced that the
multiplayer was going free to play i
said okay this is how they're going to
try to bring halo
to 2021 and and and and bring it to the
masses in a way that's appealing to the
masters of the people that are playing
fortnight to the people that are playing
apex you know it's going to be a
platform yeah exactly
so if they release the multiplayer
first first of all it has to be it has
to be a complete sweet it cannot be half
baked when it comes out
so if they're going to do that sure give
me that entire suite
and make it you know make it be
fantastic if it's fantastic
then you get people excited for the
single player product right
okay and you can take you can take more
time to bring out the single player
product
um because at the end of the day as much
as people love the halo story that you
know chief story and the lore
they're going to stick around for the
multiplayer that's where i i agree with
you but to a point
i think the halo fans the the single
players
is just as important it's one of those
rare games or absolutely for me it is
right
yeah because like if you look at it from
a halo standpoint
like it's one of the very few
first-person shooters that if the
story's bad it's going to get
obliterated
like because these days you don't see
call of duty being attacked too much for
a single player like
they might you know it might get
mentioned but like if a halo single
player is bad
it will bring that whole score down like
two points yeah you're 100 right because
the identity of call of duty is
multiplayer yeah
the identity of halo is the big man in
the green artifact
you are 100 right they need to stick
single player and i totally agree that
multiplayer needs to be a free-to-play
platform that doesn't
like this is where you're going to get
rotating tournaments and rotating
playlists and
there's going to be seasonal events and
you know this is where you're going to
spend your time if you're a halo fan
right after you
after you wrap up the halo infinite
story you're coming back
day after day today and you know bro
free to play yeah
i'm okay with that model as long as they
do it good yes
because i feel like destiny i love the
gameplay
but they don't do that part good yeah
i'll tell you this though in terms of
the single player as well though if
they're treating that as a platform as
well too right because they're talking
about
you're going to have you're going to
have pretty much free reign of an entire
halo ring right right
they're separating it but you're these
these these uh
combat engagements are going to be
bigger than we've ever seen before so
if they handle story kind of that way
too whether you're constantly adding to
things you can and opening up things you
can do in that ring like okay in
in three months we're gonna have uh some
dlc that opens up this part of the ring
that you weren't able to access before
that sort of stuff as well like if we've
seen what adding narrative to a game
that doesn't have it like a fortnight
exactly easy
you would do it so good i don't know i
like this i'm saying you you know when
callus's ship showed up in orbit
i'm just saying like no maybe
truth shows up at this rate you would do
it so well brandon
don't encourage him i i i knew it was a
good a good idea to have you honest
again oh i knew it was good
i don't know whose side i'm on right now
i'm just trying to be you're setting the
destiny fans continue
he's just he's here for the smoke that's
all right yes yes ready grant is for the
smoke i like it continue
so that's it i mean you can do so many
special things with both
aspects of this game it's just a matter
of bringing you know taking your time at
this point
i don't really even care about the
release date give me
a fantastic product yeah that's it
lord king kong patiently waiting
patiently
are we sure he's still alive yeah is he
still breathing
he had a lot to say you know i got a
salute i got to sleep with bro um he had
a lot to say when the news first broke
out about the delay and
obviously the stuff and he has some
heartfelt
words to the you know to the realm in
343 he felt strongly
so i want to know where you at with this
latest information sir
did we identify the slacker
that's the slacker been identified
people act like this wasn't gonna happen
you hired two individuals to
to run story and one to run multiplayer
first of all they were showing you a
division right there
within itself okay so once you
understood that was gonna happen
it was uh are they gonna drop it a
single player early first
or are they gonna drop multiplayer uh i
think our strategy is to drop the
multiplayer get enthusiasm back
into it have everybody run into game
pass
it's inside game pass it's a
free-to-play game and also
across microsoft platforms people can
join in they can see the game they can
feel what master chief will play like
you can start making up narratives in
your head wow
they distract you with the multiplayer
the chat said they cannot take you
seriously right now with your favorite
you can
continue though sir continue
what more do you want from me
are you not entertained what was that
gorilla that died a couple years ago
what was his name
or whatever i i watched some recipes
harambees
in the chat man let's get some let's say
you
serious here so
when the single player comes out see
that launching the multiplayer
will allow them to have enough time to
work on a single player
you'll you'll forget about the launch
date of the single player while you're
enjoying the multiplayer
and once that happens once the single
player comes out
i gotta i gotta get off the screen
continue i just
i don't look i just listen that the
single player
will be exactly what we wanted it to be
didn't get enough
master chief in in five i thought five
was pretty good
uh but obviously people didn't like lock
well they just gave me the game wasn't
good well you gotta attribute it it's
just they didn't like lock
because you know what every time they
allowed you to play a different
character
in halo people were really upset with it
when you played the arbiter
people were really pissed off yeah but i
feel like by the end people like the
arbor they just didn't do a good job
they just they just didn't do a good job
building lock as a character
and that was the issue like if you look
at it from halo 5 there was literally a
whole chapter talking to three people
an entire chapter yeah
anyway like i was saying that game would
to me was
uh real pretty good what they should
have did was allow you
to play as chief more because they gave
you a false narrative
all that stuff is gone and i talked for
who head does it fall on
the next person to walk away is the
person that
is really the problem they let the first
do it out they see the transition they
see the narrative
and they're like okay okay next guy
and the next guy that goes out you're
going to see that the project is going
to take off how it's supposed to be
i'm telling you and you know phil took
everything on his shoulders
because right at the end of the day he
watched the clip
right now it's not his fault that
somebody grabbed the npc
shout out to craig craig
but it happened for the best all right
because they would have shipped that
game with us they had monster and
everything ready
yeah all the stuff all that promo
everything was ready
you were gonna get that game november um
hella high water how it looks
right and i'm i'm happy that it got
delayed and we'll eat next year
or the year after making multiplayer
next year
all right so you're cool you're cool
with the separation yes all right
can i ask you guys one question real
quick would you think it's time
okay okay okay okay i just quick
question yes or no do you think it's
fair that 343 should be like leading the
example of all the studios
leading one example like they're the
ones that that has the most funding
they're the ones that
has the halo ip like i feel like they
should be like
the top of the line a long time ago
ripped that from them
a long time ago i told you get that out
of their hands like look and so
until you're king i can't take you
seriously
i told you that they should not have had
that once they showed that they couldn't
do it
but so problem was they did they didn't
have enough studios
yeah in order to do that they have the
studios
now and they have the first person
shooter gods
right so if you don't i can't with them
if without the mouth slightly moving
that's the [ __ ] that get me ready just
slightly in and out
[Laughter]
[Music]
so they can definitely get that game up
and running and
moving at a fast pace to give you a halo
feel a different and i truly honestly
believe
they're going to start moving people
around to help out with the project the
project is in good hands
they have the funding but 343 i'm
guaranteeing
this is their last halo they're done
with that with with halo franchise
they're from fair enough something to do
i don't think that's happening good yeah
all right uh so we have pixel but g
with the five dollar super chat um seems
people are overly stuck
on visuals the gameplay looks damn good
damn good uh
cheers lords in chat november baby
then we have rain g4 with the five
dollars which had 360 did not launch
with halo 3 and the game was great when
it was released
even though receiving criticism for not
launching with halo 3.
yeah i remember that i remember that
that they felt sort of
since they were coming out a year before
sony they didn't really need
that and they had a i mean 360 launch is
kind of crazy yeah
think about it um then we have john b
with the 5 super chat what if halo
multiplayer comes out on all consoles in
2020
and single player in 2021 only on the
series consoles
yeah i think they're i think they're too
committed
to pull that yeah yeah they took a
minute but but really i mean we
guys we've seen precedent for splitting
a property up between the single and
multiplayer right like look
what's going to happen with cyberpunk
look what happened with gta gta online
fortnite was a single-player game before
multiplayer came out and
became what it is today i reviewed the
single player of fortnite
and i'm like this game isn't going
anywhere save the world and i'm very
happy to be wrong
when the multiplayer came back
afterwards yes
game became what it is so i don't think
there's any problem seeing a halo
infinite single player and a halo
infinite
multiplayer suite that's going to last
you a decade right those will be
different products they'll all still be
in the halo universe but
people will gravitate toward what they
like what they think that's fair game
yeah
fair enough so i'll be caught up we have
a mexican zoidberg with the two dollar
super chat someone tell king to stop
monkeying around
oh my god what is it oh my goodness
shout out to uh
confusion yo i'm done with you i'm
getting my thoughts off
shout out to pike confusion forgetting
that probably the 13th code that i put
in the chair
no no i'll make my point quick because
we ran along with this topic um look
you know i'll be honest i'm a
traditionalist
you guys are making sense with the
separating and
i get it you know what i'm saying i get
it i get the free to play thing i i
truly do
and it probably will be okay but my old
og
self can't stand by and them separate
this game not only you're going to
separate this game
monkey business it's just like
you you've all like to me it's optics
you've already got people upset when
they've seen how this thing shout out to
jess he said it looked like a lego game
right
just go to the windows
you've already been meme to death right
we cool with the delay i think the fans
say you know what it took
gumption i agree with king especially
after the bethesda
right because like i believe that let's
be real we all know halo infinite was
synonymous with the series x launch
that thing if you you guys have the
series x
the back of the box is halo infinite
like that thing was planned
to ship with it oh
that's fire that's fine oh i'm so jelly
right now i'm so
jelly that man got that fish it is heavy
it's heavier i think it's like made of
concrete do me a favor grab it
and then like put your hand on top is it
hot does your hand burn
because that's the rumor the room is
cool no no that's that's blown out of
proportion it is is it hot
it's as hot as any other console it's
not bad at all you know i i don't know
brandon i i assume that that
background's fake and
your whole house caught on fire
i'm going to give you the exclusive
right now i'm in real 3d meats
salute the lord ready with that
exclusive man look i'll make it quick
look
selfishly man i i just feel you owe it
to the base
and the optics to ship a complete
package we
wait i think the base would wait i think
they're more comfortable with waiting
and getting right now the only thing
well i will say
lord brandon i feel it i completely
agree at this point with this amount of
investment
like it's coming hella high water like
this thing's coming out
like whether it's you know saying you
know bad or not but i think that you
know i do have a little confidence in
statin
you know obviously he's one of the ogs
you know and
you know i mean i don't know if chris is
being labeled as the fall guy here but
you know he he was politely showing the
door in my opinion you know saying these
type of moves
you know saying so you know at the end
of the day
i do think you know again i don't know
what's going on in that studio
but i do feel there is some
mismanagement going on
because again how does that we've talked
about it before like how does that
ship you know and i mean actually the
the trailer release
and no one didn't pull anyone to the
side and say hey
this is not oh craig i'm gonna tell you
right now nobody saw craig
and everybody looked at it and they was
blowing smoke up everybody's butt
talking about how hot it was
right it hit the streets because they
were waiting in the mirror by themselves
now the world see them and they was like
oh we're not hot we don't got dancing
and we gotta cook this all right yeah
it's it's
it's it happened no i agree i agree all
i'm saying is
to me to me the bigger the egregious
thing is again if you're
you're promoting power you're promoting
the series x as the most
and then your flagship is looking like
that there is some disconnect
there is some something that's yeah
someone's not there
overseeing and saying no fam that's not
it
yeah that's what i said in the video
that i made a couple days ago you know
shout out to my video i was like look
like microsoft's promoting this power
and they only got 30
right and optimize games that's the
thing because now
all the eggs were in that basket for
launch you know what i'm saying
now it's such a gaping hole you know
what i'm saying i'm not trying to
reiterate the whole thing all i'm just
trying to say is this
question yes if if
halo comes out they show halo right
and it's a resounding hit right
right it it blows we'll take it i'm
talking about
back then right right the first time
they showed it let's say
a resounding hit no craig happens it's
mind-blowing right did we get the
zenimax deal
yeah i don't think the cinema
started anything to do with it yeah i
think i just wanted to be part of that
i think that was happening that's
awesome that's too big of a deal that
they
all i'm saying is you know the last
point i'll say is just that for me
the big red flag which i'm glad it got
delayed is
like you're ridiculous
the last thing is just that when i saw
that there was no ray tracing all these
next generation features that were
supposed to be there
weren't there at launch that was a red
flag to me but again statins there
i rather take their time let it cook i
don't even care 20 21
we got time just let it cook let it be a
good game that's all i got so
we caught up we got to move on man we
are caught up on super chats
all right cool solve this is you let's
get these moving places
man yeah man so uh so
they recently announced this earlier
this week they announced that uh
playstation destruction all-stars the
one of the launch games for the ps5 was
not gonna make
launch and that it was being pushed to
february but it was releasing for its
first two months out in the market it
was going to be
part of ps plus right
later in the week yeah i hear muffled
some buffalo
it might be that he's suffocating i
don't know
and then we have uh bug snacks is part
of november's ps4
what i want to know from you guys way
back when
when we talked about how does how does
pl playstation sort of compete with game
pass
we talked about the possibility of of
a more robust offering out of ps now uh
even pes plus being sort of sort of
folded into ps now which doesn't seem
like that's going to be the case at
least anytime soon
it seems like this is sort of
spotlighting ps plus
but do you think besides the fact that
these games probably did not
sort of bode well in terms of pre-orders
for both of these games right when you
think about the rest of the launch
lineup these games probably did not do
well in terms of pre-orders right but
the fact that they're willing to give
you these games that
were previously i think forty dollars
and seventy dollars at retail
uh just give them to you now in ps plus
right
is this sort of their way of trying to
increase that offering
and and sort of give you like i said
i've said this before
like a game past light like experience
light experience exactly where it's not
they're not going to give you their
aaa bangers you know and date on there
but they're willing to give you these
type of games right
when you look at a destruction all-stars
obviously multiplayer
if you look at the success that rocket
league had obviously that's that's one
way you could take it but what do you
guys think about
them putting these games into ps plus
right let's get to it um
laura brandt i don't know if you're
familiar with with their ecosystem as
much but
you know these titles were supposed to
be 70. release titles i believe you know
for players
next was well not all shout out to books
but you know you know what do you feel
you know obviously we know
what game pass brings as far as value
right
you know what do you feel about when you
hear these type of games move into the
playstation plus service like does that
that you think that they're gearing up
as far as from like a game pass like
server like what
what's your thought process on that yeah
it's it's a it's a question that they're
going to have to answer
at some point right like uh you know
you're only as good as as as competitive
as you are with your with your
competition so
you know sony doesn't have an answer to
game pass right now they have tried
iterations in the past you know
plus playstation now um there there have
been answers but nothing
nothing like and to be fair this isn't a
detriment to sony nobody has figured out
the netflix for games that they've been
talking about for 10 years
uh microsoft was really the first one
that hit on it with game pass so
um i don't envision playstation
you know plus becoming sony's answer to
game pass
i think what this is is an attempt to uh
sort of quickly inflate value of the
surface
of the surface um for its audience as
well because
you know sony's launch lineup looks way
better than microsoft
right now but microsoft has game pass so
as soon as you blow through miles
morales
what do you do right whereas with
microsoft yeah
they're not huge big next-gen games but
those will come yeah so i like i'm more
into a series x because i know what i'm
getting with it and i know
the value that is associated with it
right with tony i think they're adding
bug snacks and
destruction in order to create value for
their users
when they open their box on you know
in next week is it next week already
yeah
yeah
come on let's get close i'll get close
to that box you got your house already
absolutely you're gonna say lord alex
are you back he stepped
like he stepped away for a second but uh
sorry i'm gonna get some chatting out
there
oh there you go get it are we talking
about the playstation though yeah man
bug snacks are destruction all stars in
playstation plus
are they gearing up man look man let's
be real here those games weren't selling
like that
it was just at this point it was like
let's make our service look caught
uh uh the playstation now collection
thing
they're they're looking uh they're
trying they're not trying to compete
with game pass
they're just trying to give value over
game pass in some form that they
possibly can
so you know you you pick up a
playstation 5 you'll probably get a
month of playstation now i don't know
i don't know how playstation does their
stuff uh if you have playstation now
you'll be able to
just proactively have access to all
these games just
buying the console yep yep all good or
good little soft super chatting yourself
sir
uh we have shane tomlin with the two
pound super cat in super chat has lord
all right so uh king man what's up cause
this is soft well
um i told you i told you this was gonna
happen
and this is just a test bed jim damn
blue ryan is out here he's making his
moves and
see and what i noticed is the narrative
they start shifting the goal pools
oh well look those are not triple a
bangers man like i don't care what
you're saying that's day and day
it's inside your service
you're serving this this is this is the
beginning this is the test bed okay so
when destruction
all-stars comes out it's inside their
service
uh bug snacks hit it's inside their
service
you can run from it right
but it is inevitable it is going to
happen and he understands that
he needs to make money he wants to be
the best ceo that they have had so what
we're doing he's following
phil dominus max and william
so if why not why not take those lesser
titles
that weren't going to sell and i'm
pretty sure they saw the metrics because
now they have the metrics
they put a metrics they say okay who's
not pre-selling right
oh these dudes
you might be onto something we gotta
have these numbers
get inflated so we're gonna talk about
engagement when it comes to these games
but nobody was buying bug snacks but
was a huge joke but what now once it's
in playstation now
or or the ps plus oh the engagement is
up why because you're gonna have nothing
to play after miles
so what you're gonna do you're gonna
look towards blood snacks well it's in
there for free
whatever let me check it out then you
can see there are other games that's
inside that same service
there's nothing wrong with it i told you
i was not purchasing
any playstation plus unless they started
changing their way
factual he lowered the price he's
allowing you to get inside playstation
now
and he they did some um some playstation
collection
i'm going to give them some money for
the first two or three months to see how
it goes
they're going to get my bucks now so
why not do this you act like it's bad
this is a fantastic move because i would
have
never tried bug snacks otherwise yeah
though i'm going to try bucks x now and
i'm going to try to destruction
[Laughter]
i think that's incredible i'm done
moving on
oh okay no no we're good i'm all right
let me jump in um listen competition is
good man
competition is good for gaming i like it
man cause i'm with king i was that
copper destruction on star
and i definitely was not confident bugs
that but now
that they're in playstation plus you
know what i'm saying yo
it doesn't hurt right you just boot it
up it's there and it's downloadable no
streaming stuff
this is where i agree with king this is
it got to hit the little game pad
game pass effect you know i'm saying
competition is good make your service
more attractive
i love that kind of thing and um but the
thing i think nobody's talking about
soft that i really want to jump in is
that um
that ps plus collection yeah
that's the trojan horse to me because
when i look at that lineup
and i don't care nobody's that lineup is
fire did you see that lineup's off
yeah most of their first party stuff a
lot of third party club as well
detroit's in there fall out you know
what i'm saying
he's stupid playing those games now
keep barry out of this um but look
persona 5's in there
last of us remastered like these are
bangers from sony the minute you have ps
plus
boom right in there ratchet and clank
these are huge games infamous work
monster hunter world i'm a huge detroit
fan like
this is this is worth it and then i know
obviously the service gives you the
cloud saves right so i believe
right as well so you can do this you
don't have to do the weird wi-fi
transfer that they want you to do
if you ain't got the service but that
this adds value to the service
i like it it's a big step in the right
direction yeah so i think
when when when we first talked about
shuhei sort of getting uh you know
demoted or whatever it was um and him
being sort of in charge of
sort of the indie initiative right i
immediately thought i said this is this
is how they try to
to make ps plus or ps lps now
more robust you are going to work hard
to get games
day and date into into those services to
at least
have compete with game pass in some way
shape or form
and like i said i just think once you
start seeing the engagement numbers once
you start seeing the purchase numbers
because again
matt you know shout out to matt
piscatella he said this all the time
he's like
the moment you have that game available
to everyone
it's inevitable that the sales of it are
just going to go up right right and
it makes you wonder why is that why
would the sales of it go up when
you have it for free it's just the way
the human mind works right when you have
something
especially the way sony does it where
it's it's there for a limited time
even if third party stuff is there for
limited time right so
you'll have it for two months after that
it'll go on sale for whatever yeah but
if you like the product you're going to
go ahead and buy it
so i just think i just think these are
these are the beginnings of this this is
the
i agree i agree i think it's literally
planning to see let me get my man
schneider design real quick is he coming
for me he said but hey cog if you had a
ps4 you played those games years ago
true but the thing is you gotta
understand we can't think selfishly as
ourselves as gamers there's still going
to be new people that jump into the
ecosystem and people
who for financial reasons maybe they
didn't cop they just they hadn't gone
by i mean at all i was waiting for this
now
and here i am
let's let's be realistic here like us as
consumers that have bought these these
titles throughout the years
we have every right to want them to
carry on to the next platform
and with enhancements and stuff like
that let's get this super chat we gotta
i don't know about all that but
[Laughter]
let the baby walk first
and listen let's get to walking let's go
we have
no ducks giving and dancing with the two
pounds super chat i'm so far behind
still no king outbursts
our topics today are very clean and nice
[Laughter]
wholesome cake yes yes so you all sets
off
yeah we're all good all right no no
final topic let's get moving because we
are running behind and i want to keep
this man hostage a little brandon's got
a lot of things you got to do but lord
king man you you surprised the realm
stitch this is not a lord cognato topic
for the record you always
accuse me of the switch topics
[Laughter]
nintendo for the win baby [ __ ] with you
lord king you are up nintendo direct
yeah i gotta hear why i gotta hear why
you what this topic let's go tell you
something okay so lo and behold i'm
watching youtube
time we're so rude
but i got you i'm watching youtube and
then
i see a nintendo direct pop up i'm like
what
all right let me check it it's a mini so
when they said it they said that it was
their partners direct
so i said okay let me check it out and
see what they have right
all right um that uh bravery
to fire i'm gonna tell you right now
when i was looking at it
this joint look next gen what the hell
are they using right so
i'm looking at all the games that
they're being shown
what people didn't understand and i
remember
last year they did resident evil
and they did it on the clouds right
and um if you were able to do a vpn
you were able to get in on the cloud
streaming and
cheated so when i saw it the graphics
was incredible and i'm like wow
they are able to go to the next gen
without changing the hardware in
two weeks well in one week now it was
two weeks then
in one week these next generation
hallways is coming out and our main
concern was
how is this switch going to keep pace
well nintendo just showed you how they
will keep pace with the cloud-based
infrastructure
and they launched it so you can check it
with control and i like
actually not that bad either yeah and it
has
ray tracing yes performance modes
when these two next generation consoles
come out next week and there's no ray
tracing but nintendo
look at them
we know literally came in and they
always doing their own thing
they took the rug and they pulled it out
from under these two feet
and they said you don't have to upgrade
anything
all you got to do is have a stable
connection see you next week
and they lost you right now and they
don't care nintendo continues to move by
the beat of their own drum
i think they don't see that nintendo
direct and work
excited as much as i am so just just
question from the ignorant people like
me that have no idea how they're doing
this um
it so it's it's like a streaming service
that will be on the
the nintendo switch so you buy the game
and you could stream it to the next yeah
so pretty much there's a demo right now
the way it works is
you go to nintendo eshop you download
the demo for um control
right it's like basically i guess their
cloud client or whatever it may be and
then they let you do that for free so
they let you get like a stage in
you pick your modes performance or with
the ray trace and on so i think it's
like a 60 frames per second mode versus
at 30 frames per second with ray tracing
you play it they let you get about a
stage as soon as the stage and it's like
all right yep
that was a nice demo um 39.99 if you
want the game
but it's the deluxe edition i believe
the definitive version
yeah of the game to me to me when it
comes to stuff like that
it's like look like that's cool and all
but there ain't no way
i'm gonna pay full price what's that
full price but i assume
if third-party titles are gonna cut well
yeah you get what i'm saying like from
what i
why i didn't pay for patrol but like i'm
not paying that kind of money
for a full price game to stream
something like fair enough
it's just not especially on the switch
if that game is available somewhere else
it's being played there
listen i'll i'll get to me with it when
it's my turn but i want to get a little
brandon in man
um i don't know if you've heard about
this uh streaming technology believe it
so far
resident evil like king said hitman will
be another one
and then um also control which has a
demo now like what do you think about
this strategy
by nintendo switch yeah um
i mean i think smart money is you never
bet against nintendo
so nintendo doesn't need to beat
microsoft and sony
at their game nintendo's not even
playing that game factual
nintendo just needs to make it possible
for its people
for for its audience to enjoy what it
does and i think this goes a long way
in that right like it's not trying to
compete and be the biggest and best and
shiny
uh piece of hardware piece of plastic in
your house but
if it can allow you to experience things
close to or
at level with other consoles you know
and
the cloud element is just another tool
in its box that enhances what nintendo
does
really really well which is unique
experiences with its first party lineup
that you literally cannot find anywhere
absolutely and you know brian uh lord
brandon uh one of the biggest things
that i have to give to them
is how confident they are in this
they're like we're gonna let you play
we're gonna let you dabble a little bit
in these games to show you that
if you buy this game this is the type of
experience you're going to have with it
and share it like multi consoles such as
myself you know
i might not play it on that platform but
like my cousin storm
he's only a switch gamer so that's that
that's his only
option and when he can play the control
he's like yo i can still play your game
on the switch so it doesn't matter right
yeah no fair enough it's
good these are fantastic points lord
soft man where you at
uh switch gang cloud gaming what's going
on man switching the cloud
i made fun about the vaseline version
but that the fact of the matter is
we got the definitive version of control
saints off who's got the definitive
version
as of right now forget about next gen
switch company hot
they have to say look because when they
did it when they did it for res evil
right and i first saw it i'm like okay
they're not completely confident because
it's only it's only in japan and they
don't want to like
they didn't it didn't feel like they
were necessarily confident what
they would get on the on the western
front so um
the fact that they and what i heard
about the the company that they're using
for the clouds
it's a very small company right it's not
they're not using this you know
azure or anything like that right um but
the fact that they can
put that out there and just see the
reaction that people have
the experience that people have and
they're willing to do this it's
it's nintendo being forward thinking in
a way that you don't expect
nintendo to be forward thinking like a
lot of times nintendo's forward thinking
like
when we saw the switch and what it was
we're like okay obvious
but only nintendo would think of that
right
it's they they're always they're in
their own yeah
they're in their own lane and usually
they always hit
in that lane so for them to look at the
general landscape and say okay how can
we
fit our fit into this general landscape
as is moving forward with the cloud
gaming stuff like
that um it's it's kind of fantastic it's
kind of fantastic and if you do have the
connection to do it
yeah yeah and and you're not gonna you
know you're not ready to invest 500
in a new console uh in a couple of weeks
then this is this is crazy this is
fantastic and then
in addition to that you they still
continue to be sort of the
the indie machine right a lot of a lot
of indie games that come day and date
to pc exactly the pcr are making their
way to switch
very early
time on you we you don't like nintendo
toys
this is not about nintendo talk listen
guys make sure y'all stick around the
giveaway is going to be
uh at the end of the show so do not
leave
if you're a member of the realm yes or
if you're a patreon member because
you want to know if you won that xbox
series x or y that playstation 5.
stick around yes sir
so yeah i mean beyond that like i said
before they had the uh
the uh age of calamity demo they had a
couple other smaller games they had
uh no more heroes one and two remastered
actually dropping yesterday so it's
stuff like that that they do we've
talked about how nintendo's been
relatively quiet this year
um obviously covet has affected
everybody but i think everything they've
dropped
uh it's been fine you haven't had the
big banger right we haven't gotten
metroid or we haven't gotten the next
mario bades
yeah i think they filled the void pretty
well with with the stuff that they're
doing
so yeah i'll jump here i'll make it
quick um look you know shout out to the
direct shout out to king
for putting me on to a nintendo direct
that i missed
so shout out to him on that because i
definitely missed it but yeah bravery
default
two looked fire i thought it was a
strong showcase
you know um obviously the uh what was it
uh addict the
the prequel to breath of the wild where
it's gonna be like dynasty warriors they
actually look good i thought it looked
good i actually
yeah i actually looking forward to that
yeah it actually look it looked good i i
can't front they had a couple of games
with no more heroes
you know what i'm saying shout out to
our boy neil who's a big fan neil jones
development we had on last week he's
huge fan of that
but sarv and king you guys are on fire
i honestly think this could be the
secret weapon man
because i'm with you i'm with yourself
in the sense that
i don't attribute nintendo
to cloud and forward thinking i'm gonna
be honest like i feel like they're in
their
their lane they are perfectly fine at
doing what they're doing the numbers and
mpd clearly is in their favor since this
you know switch has been doing what it's
doing but when i look at it i always
felt like remember king we kept saying
switch pro switch pro when is it coming
you're gonna have to do something my
biggest question to you is if this is
if they really perfect this do you think
a switch pro is ever going to happen
it does happen i think to me they're
doing this makes me feel like that
they're not really interested in a
switch pro
i feel like if they were interested in
breeding third-party
platforms they wanted to make a stronger
call so this wouldn't be necessary
i mean i will say this i think it's one
of those things where it doesn't
make it urgent now like as urgent they
they're sitting pretty they're still
raking in the door they're still the
revenue the games their
first party ips go through the roof we
already see i think for me
again with king and solve i'm completely
agree is that i just wondered how they
were going to survive when you have
these high fidelity games
that you know as soft puts it the
vaseline version
ain't no scaling down to that tegra chip
sorry but i think i think the biggest
thing is is
like the people that game on those
platforms they don't care about that
but they just they don't you're right
nintendo has its own lane but
it is something to be said to have an
ecosystem
that might not necessarily ever see a
game like control hitman
cyberpunk or whatever right and now able
to play these
next generation experiences and i'mma be
real with y'all i tested that demo
latency wasn't that bad man it was
actually
really playable and responsible now the
question i want to flip back to you king
because this is a great topic
was that we know you know
phil dominus maximus spencer oh dower
really is as you call him
um we know he is a fan of xcloud and
getting game pass onto different
platforms he's cool he said he's cool
with that
to me when i see nintendo dabbling in
this forward thinking
could this potentially set up you know
what i'm saying
in the future maybe nintendo microsoft
play nice little azure server deal go
down you know xbox game pass apps cake
by reaching for the stars i've been
watching
what he's been saying lately i've been
watching all his interviews
and he wants to win this generation
all that conversation is after he
conquers them
so after he conquers them then
that can happen but right now the main
concern is
a successful launch uh maintaining a
steady flow of consoles because i
feel that whoever has the availability
that's going to determine the first to
10.
and the first to 10
is going to be uh the actual winners now
10 million technically game pass is
already
at 10 already right oh god okay here we
go
i'm just saying like if you're looking
at it as a a
platform and game pass is a platform
it already has a foothold going into the
next generation
as a service well they're they're using
it as a platform because
every game that they showed at the uh
the uh
the the what was that the june show
yeah all those games are in game pass
right they're using this as a platform
moving forward because
they told you they're looking at ruku
stix type of uh
services things that you can just take a
controller so you're going to be able to
purchase a controller with a little ruco
stick for like 100 bucks
throw it inside and play game pass this
listen
that is a platform within itself they're
trying to establish
that and then they can worry about other
stuff later i don't see them
putting their stuff on playstation i
don't know or nintendo
anytime soon after he conquers that part
then i don't like you they will go there
to be honest with you i feel like he's
using
you know the switch people he's using
the phone to get to them
if you want to game on like ro uh you
know
if you're on playstation you got pc in
the roku thing
like he ain't looking at those consoles
listen i feel like all i'm going to say
on
is this i wouldn't be mad if it happened
i could hope i said but the last thing
i'll say is as far as the new switch
is like a switch pro whatever hey you
throwing some bluetooth support
you're throwing maybe wi-fi six off you
know what i'm saying yeah
get your infrastructure up if if
nintendo is going to commit to cloud
get your two channels
control yes the joy cons that don't
drift
and we gonna be all right
so that's where i'm back with it man we
got a lot look we got a lot to go to
first of all let's do this poll and get
a little branded on it because i know
i've kept him super long and then we'll
do our giveaways
but uh sorry if you got anything on the
super chat before we move on to the poll
and get out of here
i think we're good we're good okay cool
so um yeah
newport we're up as soon as i said oh my
brother boom
hold on let me get bro what up boom
you see what you're missing boom shout
out to tell our super chat
for my brother double barrel gaming mr
booster l supporting my brothers also
could you give
mrs boom a very happy 50th birthday
she is absolutely amazing and my best
friend
yes happy birthday to mrs boom salute
the rounds a little double barrel game
that's my guy right there always
putting in the work he's got like five
shows this week i already know he's
cooking up
you know what i said oh lord stitch is
coming for me follow
super chat [ __ ] stop your games are
maxing resolution at 720p
it's not that hard to stream let's be
real they still don't have party chat
listen man you gotta have a foundation
you gotta start somewhere man let's be
real here
was he wrong he ain't wrong they gotta
fix their party chat
shout out to luke lordy and separate
ghost my man turn out some chat salute
to the lords you already know expansion
podcast yo check him out man great audio
podcast
that's my guy when you go invite me go
sign guy ain't getting no invite what's
up anyway
continue but look new all people we got
to get about here um
with halo infinite losing another top
director during this development cycle
which course of action do you think 343
should take
prior to releasing the game the choices
are
a scrap the initial vision entirely
remake with a new graphics engine that's
what i said
get the functional part out to the
masses separate single player and
multiplayer
when each already brandon agrees
c delay until the completed
version of halo infinite is right that's
the
all that damn twitter bullying did this
to my man craig the brute
wait is that is that you supposed to be
cracked the broom is that what's going
on
for craig for craig king is officially
known as craig the brute man that's it
man daddy's the choice is
light skin
that is the question please write the
vote when it goes up on iop
twitter lord brandon ty ralph senior
editor of
ign an absolute pleasure rocked with us
the entire and we kept them hostage in
all type of halloween suits
and the man is busy thank you for having
me
it has been a blast thank you brother
where can the five people find you
and uh what do you got going on sir uh
you can find me on ign
and you can be on twitter it's just my
name at brandon tyrell i'm not on it a
ton
but i usually reply to people so
absolute brother absolute project
thank you so much a huge huge fan of
what you do man
keep the hard work work ethic up and
again an inspiration your story was
truly inspiring we love to hear that
kind of stuff here in the realm of
question welcome back anytime
you're an honest fan so you know what we
got to do today baby make sure my get
you started
let's go here we are right there oh look
at that conference [ __ ] look at that nfc
chip my bad
leave here and go start my pre-game
ritual exactly
soft kick i want to say y'all chose to
him before before he bounced out for
no time oh absolutely man uh big shout
out to brandon tyrell for coming through
um
it it it's true as somebody who watches
idea in a lot you see
his entire journey when he came on and
you only saw him on a few things you're
like who is this guy
and then little by little he just he
starts bringing more things and then you
realize that he's
he's part of the permanent staff so i
just happy to hear your story the fact
that you know
another indication that hard work always
pays off
for if you're passionate about something
you want to do something i mean
same with miranda when miranda was on
she talked about just
the hustle just possible and you will
get what you are
definitely what you deserve when i
really really became a fan of brandon
was when actually when
uh obviously twitter and the vitriol
sometimes
uh miranda got attacked for something
and brandon pounced oh no his gun was
wrecked
don't get locked up really i went back
and deleted those thank you friend
please
i was like i came on
the truth of the matter is you catch you
catch a lot yeah you know
when you're online and um you know we
all have thick skin you got to have
thick skin
right you're not going to survive
don't mess with her yeah don't mess with
her she's about to smoke she she's
little but she
she's got yeah she's got a she packs
yeah
she definitely hit me with a couple of
the truth of it is you catch one of us
on the on a bad day and
you know like we're not fair enough and
we know how the internet is man but yeah
thanksgiving
lord uh addict king you wanna get some
outros to the to the brandon
definitely ryan you're one of the
highlights of uh unlocked uh miranda's a
little less after sh
she fell down a rake man she hit me with
that one soon i was like
i was like i'm gonna have to stop
messing with this unlocked as much now
i'm joking
i appreciate you coming on man it was a
it's a it was a great conversation
lord king kong thoughts to brandon on
his way out
it's a pleasure having you i've noticed
that uh is a commentary
with all the unlocked guys uh and and
woman
um y'all all are diligent
patient thoughtful and hard-working
and it's a wonder why the team works
together because
y'all all share the same traits if you
listen to all of your stories
you're all over achieving actual
brian's story was amazing too yeah but
but it's not even like overachievers you
get exactly what you work for
yeah so you're exactly where you needed
to be because you worked as hard as you
did
for it yes and it is amazing to see
and i truly appreciate you even coming
on the show
and sharing your story with us yes uh
your gaming history
and even sticking all the way through
with me in a monkey
this is a little highlight of my day
salute to brandon for loving the smoke
and the foolishness of the eye alone
i guess to close on that yeah i will say
that you know if if
like you know i mentioned during my
story that there were times where i
definitely thought like
it's just not going to happen right um
but stick with it
and you know
finds work that you that speaks to you
and it resonates to you
and then just try to mimic it do your
best to to just
put out the product that you think is
the best product out there and stick
with it and it's gonna there's gonna be
a bunch of bumps
and uh it's gonna be hard but you know
if you do it long enough you get good
enough at it that
good things are gonna happen yeah and
you know what's funny uh little brandon
is a
iop have the same bumps you know there's
times where we felt like maybe we ain't
you know maybe this ain't going to go
anywhere and then you know we
every year we keep oh my god no no no
king wasn't believable
i've never thought that every every year
you know we keep growing and growing and
growing so you know
yeah this is definitely in a monkey suit
and this is where it all takes off and
this is where it takes off this is this
is it
this is a great conversation great group
of guys it's a really cool vibe
thank you it's like just having a
conversation with your buddies so keep
keep doing what you're doing guys it
means a lot to us brother thank you
enjoy your sunday golden honest
and i don't know you soon brother have a
good one man all right take it easy
thanks again for having me you already
know any time brother we have you back
too
all right bye bye lord soft it is that
time brother i got one thing real quick
before we go
into that is look uh you know i i did a
a giveaway for the members in youtube
and i did one for the chat
uh after the show i'm gonna put one up
on patreon
and for all the patreon lawyers
definitely go out there and check that
out
right oh i wanted to say one thing
because i did want to have a different
topic but i couldn't be able to use that
topic
but i told y'all about big navy
[Music]
all right give me a second okay
uh we got the raven flow with the 10
super chat i predicted playstation and
nintendo yield and game pass
gets on the platforms microsoft will
claim victory on console based
uh console-based gaming through
subscriptions the potential cap is
150 to 200 million subs next netflix is
100 million yeah i mean
again i don't think that happens
while phil is in charge because phil is
still always going to give us a box
it's it took them years to get that much
subscriptions
yeah so but the moment that phil is not
in charge and they decide that
they don't want to make an xbox box
anymore yeah i think that's the play
right i think the moment they perfect
the online stuff that will happen
but right now we're years away from that
being perfected so
no doubt no doubt what else we got what
is the list 22 with the five dollar
super chat i've been busy today but
jumping into the show to show my support
salute
10 more days xbox series
crazy i gotta
yeah we got the wise old gamer with the
five dollars which that hey guys i don't
know what tomorrow holds but i want to
say that although it took me a while to
find you it is an honor to have met you
guys thank you sir appreciate it
i'll get this game up i'll i'll get this
i mean you're gonna get our destiny on
so uh you're definitely gonna pull
through
god bless yes see you soon absolutely
we'll be playing
absolutely so we got a five dollars
picture from gaming forte
before we start this video please show
support to the homie gaming addict link
to his channel will be in the
description
only if you won this bet all right now
let let me
let me briefly talk about that me and
forte had a bet who made the most
content
in the month of october would get uh
they the loser would have to show the
winners channel on their
uh on their channel it was like for like
15 to 20 videos
well yesterday laura cognito can put to
contest to this i went home
and i helped with uh with something for
iop i even said
yo i can make this video right now and
be forte
but i didn't because i was like i might
as well just go ahead and tie with it
because we both
we're slacking this one exactly so
what's it you're both great content
creators subscribe to the channel
time all right you actually read the
super chat
so we have gaming 4k with the five
dollar super chat before no
i read it ready okay okay i didn't even
hear that i didn't hear that he was
wrong
i write it and then i i talked about the
bet yeah
right so thanks saying time on me you
ain't even
i don't know listening a little suspect
that was yeah i say time uh
people want to win this thing man come
on all right
we have the safe space invader with the
two dollar super chat
one of my favorites along with will beau
gadkins yes
yes we have chet ball twisted cal-el
with the two-pound super chat salute to
the king
love ilp salute and we have
lady boom josette rivera with the 20
super chat
thank you for the well wishes i feel
blessed to have reached
uh this milestone even more blessed for
the love i have received from everyone
uh virtual hugs to all fans
happy birthday lady mrs blue that's
what's up
what else we got we have jean marc louis
with the 2 super chat what about vr jim
ryan
what about vr i smoke
gamestop isn't buying any playstation
vrs
they're not buying any vr's really none
let me
let you know right now that's a very bad
indicator
mind you they're still selling because i
was looking into trading in my oculus
quest to get the questions
obviously they're trying to get rid of
that stuff yeah so they're not taking
trading though but they are selling the
quest too though
yeah but they're not taking no
playstation vrs
didn't they just make a statement saying
that it's a time giveaway time
just because i gave you guys that that
email dope
daddy all right
last super chat we have regulated 951
with the two dollar super chat
lord nappy's theory coming into fruition
is it that time it is that time ladies
and
gentlemen after months and months of uh
preparation and i won't say preparation
but uh speculation
it is time to give away these consoles
again oh
we have l boogie great show can't
believe you all ended this
this this early he's all on the 10th
l bugs no doubt al um
so uh full disclosure guys wrong women
gaming salute they salute subscribe to
the channel
we need to get them back home yeah we
gotta get them back that was a fun show
that was a fun show
so uh full disclosure guys as we stated
earlier uh it has been a bit difficult
to get our hands on these consoles
so we do not have them as of yet so if
you have a pre-order or something like
that and you happen to win the console
don't go canceling your pre-order yes
please don't don't do that don't do that
everyone will get the winners will get
that console we just we cannot guarantee
anything
near um you're going to get the console
go get your console
all right if you have a pre-order
continue with your pre-order exactly
then when it comes
give it back
let's get it so all right no doubt so
i'm going to share my screen
now and i'm going to do that in a moment
give me a second
focus is on solve slow-mo says how's the
winner being joke make sure you click
his screen when he shares it i got it
i'm going to take my monkey hands and
stick us out of back not today
all right are we on it yeah you're on
your screen
okay so you have it says random name
picker oh no
you're we're not seeing the [ __ ] i don't
see anything yet i mean you see the shed
fire
you share the application or the window
or it's the window well it's sharing my
entire window so this is the window that
i'm sharing you have to
do you have two screens no no it's just
one screen
uh-huh this is this is what we get for
now this is what we get with our testing
okay
awesome it works for me
all right hold on hold on hold on yeah
it works for him are you yeah you got to
use that icon
because usually it says application or
window and your entire
application window or the entire screen
okay here we go let's see
all righty okay okay okay there we go
there we go there we go
there we go now you just click your
screen
yeah yeah i click this great he good he
good all right so uh
first off i want to thank all of you
guys who have supported
us both on patreon and youtube um if you
look at the names down here these are
190 names so we have
and i know some of them are doubled up
so at the very least we probably have
at least 170 70 like unique followers
thank you guys for supporting us this is
all cool
daddy said we're about to see some see
some big
don't worry about his url stop that
well what he chooses to visit on his
time
is his business the good thing about our
our border and our overlays you can't
see his url
everybody's looking at the top i know
everybody's so
nosy at somebody's screen this is all
works no
work stuff no your man said big booty
freak i'm done continue
now keep in mind now keep in mind i
don't know anyone in the chat that
doesn't know this but
if you were subscribed to both the
member and the patreon you get two votes
but that's why you'll see some of these
have two yeah scroll through that list
real quick so people can see who you are
their names are there and if you you're
twice i didn't put your name next to
your name's next to each other so
they're both in there just so don't
worry about that all right
you got that double chance because you
were in both the patreon
you you extra for that i hope i hope
it's somebody that bothers me on twitter
because sometimes sometimes the
algorithm is funny and it may pick
yo slow-mo said i ain't stuck we ain't
starting this until i see my dad
your slow is stupid
there you go yo i'm a member too i could
win
yo y'all gonna stop with this i don't
see why y'all
which one are we giving away first oh
let's give away that
let's get the playstation first let's go
playstation
xbox would be so we see the best game
with the best for last
three of you the three of you decide i
say playstation first
i say playstation let's put out voters
all right ladies and gentlemen
the winner of the iron lords podcast
playstation 5 giveaway
now we gotta have a real one
[Music]
is a shill the perfect playstation
winner
yo
[Applause]
look jacob how does it feel for all that
trolling to pay off
is that the real jw is that
i don't think that's him i don't think
that's a real job
yeah that would be too much work for
jade
that would be hilarious all right
congratulations jay duff is a shill i
know you want to be uh
secretive about who you are but you're
gonna have to give me them you're gonna
have to give me that government
name and address son congratulations
he got the biggest modem known to man so
as we know
his name goes right back in yep so
there's no names removed from this
so let's get rid of this let's get let's
give away this xbox series
[Music]
all right i'm about to hit the button
you guys ready power your dreams this is
for the big one
baby big money no whammies no whammies
and the winner of
[Music]
oh
i don't remember where big mad mo is
from i if it's on youtube
it's tough because we don't have any
other information so if big mad
big mad mo happens to not be in the chat
today if you guys
know him yes make sure you let him know
that he's won this console and we need
his information yes yes yes
that well we have we have some
information we'll just have to confirm
our two-step authentication process for
you frauds
try to act like you it might not be you
bad boy
and remember if you're in the patreon
remember i'm putting that up after the
show so you can still win
something if you go over there yes cat
daddy said is there a time limit on the
clinton hey look at the thirst
you'll get back in 24 hours
once again one shot uh big shout out to
cat daddy lerp yeah
the xbox series next is is a donation
care
pack a cat daddy lurk cat daddy's one
one of our most
avid and loyal uh supporters he said
that he wanted to do this for the
community so big shout out
and he better be in that destiny rate
yes day one day one sir
no doubt so uh congratulations to the
winners um
it like i said before it is because of
you guys that we can even do this that
we can even
start doing this do we um like that is a
real question we give them like a month
to respond like um
i mean we again we don't want you know
sometimes people
for whatever reason they're just not
online or whatever we'll do our very
best
we gotta get a shout out to me i have a
confession i'm j
doubles of shill and
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like we figured yo you got a week to
respond bro like come on
right which i think that's fair lords
yeah we give you the next time
let's stay tuned let's say two let's see
you got all this week and next week if
you ain't there by then we got three
months
redo it cause you knew it was going you
to do it was going down all right then
give it a week you got to wait
by next sunday
i know he watches it right now he's
shaking in the room like
he said i also have a confession i am
jolly time
you know first off you know i want to
thank everyone in that chat
especially you know cat daddy for
sponsoring the giveaway yeah uh
you know we we do these giveaways and we
do you know
the giveaways on patreon members because
you guys have been such a good community
to us
uh you you made me wear some some
so uh man overalls you made me wear that
nonsense uh you know you're about to see
that the members or you're about to see
king almost die with the chip challenge
so you're about to see that
shadow yeah how long have you gotten
away
from definitely gonna be this week um we
gotta figure out
that i have the chip in my possession
the chip is here
and just just to clarify uh i don't know
if this is still going down cognito's
supposed to be in the room with you
right
oh that wasn't confirmed but i know i
could pull up though
yeah you know i think it would be better
if you did it you both did it the same
route
i'm not saying both of you i'm saying
you do it he's in the room
i think that would be the funniest thing
like put in the chat do you guys think
cognito should be there obviously it's
up to them
but i i would like to see that man yo
every time we talk about this challenge
i start sweating
i start sweating already i don't know
listen i've seen people
eat it i've seen whatever it is i've
seen a few people eat it that had no
issues
i think you're okay i'm covered
he can't drink milk so he that's out of
the question and plus you know
especially if they're able to do it it
shows that we actually know each other
in these streets
i don't drink milk so yeah like you said
that's what i said you know yeah i got
something for that man i'm ready
i got that
said you had ice cream no i got
something i got something else all right
so you cook it let's get the super chat
he's going to cut his tongue
the only thing that works through
bribery is our monthly giveaways not
these these are on the up and up
everything else is bribery though
i like that new tier the king has
swimming on ice water
swimming on ice water
i'm doing what i'm scared of you sorry
they're really trying to kill you
so y'all caught up yeah we're good yeah
man salute everybody man
fun show a lot more stuff cooking in the
round everybody today our shows are
ready right we're good we're good ready
yeah okay
i'm saying but yo november gonna be lady
got some fun stuff cooking up
possibly i'm selling mad consoles
king's gonna make money you know what
i'm saying but yeah right there
flying six thousand dollars a piece
but look out for november man we
definitely obviously it's it's this
month we know the console is coming we
should
potentially have some special guests
cooking up in the realm and december
as well man that's what i got look man
love y'all
fun in the realm man salute the brandon
suit everybody enjoy your sunday anybody
got anything else before we get up out
of here i gotta go to bed yeah he got to
go to bed
like that's not gonna patron up it's
going up right now so go straight there
all right y'all we see you until next
sunday
peace
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you